Two one.
And we're live ladies and Gentlemen,
uh,
or gentlemen to the ladies and gentlemen listening.
But Youtube,
unless you have some non-binary handle that you enjoy,
it's a new world.
Uh,
please,
please introduce yourself.
Sure.
So,
uh,
I'm Dr Mychart originally from Saint John's,
Newfoundland.
Uh,
now I'm residing in London,
Ontario,
and I'm a family doctor and I've been practicing cannabis medicine for just over
five years.
And
My name is al experience.
And I used to be in New York Times reporter.
Uh,
then I became a spy novelist.
And most recently I wrote the book,
Tell Your children the truth about marijuana,
mental illness and violence,
which came out last month and,
uh,
has not endeared me to the cannabis advocacy community.
I'd say
have they,
uh,
attacked you mercilessly for this book?
Yes.
And that's okay.
Um,
uh,
I've also heard from a lot of parents,
you know,
some users,
but parents who've told me,
uh,
that the book really encapsulates their,
their family's problems in the last couple of years.
Um,
I suspect my,
my real thoughts here before we even get started is that we're going to find
that the truth is somewhere in the middle here.
Um,
I don't think marijuana is a hundred percent safe,
honestly for everybody.
I really don't,
I know too many people that have had experiences where they took too much,
particularly edibles and,
uh,
I don't,
I want to say I know anybody who had psychotic breaks,
but I know some people that freaked out for weeks,
you know,
in fact,
a,
we just had a,
a comedian here from Brazil.
Um,
a couple of days ago,
Rafi Bosstones who said he took a couple of hits of a vape pen,
he was high for 14 days,
went to a psychiatrist and he's a big guy.
He's like six foot five,
six,
you know,
and you know,
they told them to keep taking it cause you know,
he's like,
you're so big,
just keep smoking.
And so he,
he doesn't smoke.
He just kept hitting this vape pen.
He said I was high for fucking two weeks.
Yes,
you need to do it properly.
Right?
Yeah.
He's held to the same standard as any other medicines.
So you need to identify that there's risks and there's benefits to it and some
people are definitely,
you know,
going to be more susceptible to those risks.
And we need to kind of tease out those people and make sure that those people,
you know,
don't put themselves at risk.
Yeah,
I think so as well.
And this is one of the reasons why I want to state this because I'm a well known
marijuana advocate,
but I,
I do believe,
I believe absolutely there are great benefits to it.
I think there's great benefits in terms of uh,
relieving pressure,
ocular pressure for people that have glaucoma,
people with aids who are on medication,
people with cancer that are going through chemotherapy find great benefit in
terms of helping them.
And then there's also some people with autism.
I know people that their children have autism and they give them small amounts
of edible marijuana and stops
seizures.
It's incredibly beneficial in the form of CBD for a lot of different ailments.
But I think with all things,
and this is a stance that I've kind of like really come to accept over the last
few years with all things that affect the mind,
they affect everyone slightly differently.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
I'll see you wanted to say something.
They're not.
First of I,
I suspect,
you know,
there were people who said,
don't go on with Joe.
He's just going to,
you know,
he's going to try to eat you alive and,
and especially there'll be,
it'll be two on one.
I told them the truth.
First of all,
I,
I'll go on with anybody and I am glad you had me on or you're having me on
because,
uh,
you know,
Bill Maher,
he won't have me on.
He's afraid to talk to me about this.
Why,
what did he say?
Well,
he,
you know,
he told the or his people told the Simon and Schuster PR people,
uh,
we just don't want to have him on.
And a and NPR had a national NPR show,
had an interview scheduled with me,
an hour long segment,
and they canceled it.
They said,
they said,
we don't believe in the conclusions of the book.
Okay.
You don't believe in the conclusions of the book,
have me on ask me anything.
And that's why I'm so happy that you're not afraid to have me on that.
We can have a conversation that we can have a conversation come at me with any
question you want about the science.
Um,
I mean,
I'll say right off the top,
I don't think marijuana's medicine,
uh,
it has a few,
medical uses that have been,
you know,
CBD has been shown to reduce seizures in kids.
That's great.
A THC has been shown to reduce the nausea associated with chemotherapy.
That's nice.
Uh,
but for the most part,
people use THC and cannabis has recreational and toxicants.
They used them to get high the same way they use alcohol the same way they use
other drugs.
And the sooner we,
we accept that reality,
the better off we'll all be.
That this is a drug and it has risks and benefits and the risks and benefits are
different than alcohol.
They're different than other drugs.
But I don't think if you look sort of on a population level basis,
they're less than alcohol.
I don't think you can even say that.
I don't,
I really strongly disagree with that.
I mean,
you just have to look at the death rate,
right?
Uh,
you know,
more people die from alcohol then,
almost all drugs combined.
But when we're looking at cannabis,
there's zero deaths attributed to the use of cannabis itself.
Sure.
You could say,
you know,
someone could use cannabis and jump off a cliff or something like that,
but we're talking about the lethal dose.
You cannot die from cannabis.
And just based upon that alone,
it makes it much,
much safer than alcohol.
So could you say that if that is the case?
So,
okay,
so that's a really good question.
Uh,
the normal number that's used for us desks from alcohols about 90,000 now,
about 30 to 40,000 of those deaths are desk from the physical effects of
alcohol,
right?
Essentially,
liver damage,
either chronic liver damage,
you get cirrhosis,
you die.
In some cases,
you can drink so much that you kill yourself in a night.
Uh,
so that's about 30 to 40,000 deaths.
The other deaths are generally associated with alcohol,
meaning somebody drank exactly violence,
suicide,
car accidents and the,
all those numbers are basically based on studies from the 90s and before where
you know,
people looked at traffic accidents and there were certain number of those
accidents where people had a blood alcohol content of higher than 0.1.
They said,
okay,
that's an alcohol associated death.
That's a fine way to count.
As far as I'm concerned,
nobody has ever done that count for cannabis.
And I can tell you based on the,
on the tox screens that I've seen from Colorado where people,
uh,
had cannabis in their blood and committed suicide,
people have cannabis in,
there are I should say THC and their blood and uh,
and got into a fatal confrontations with police officers.
If,
if,
and when we do this number for cannabis,
which we need to do as soon as possible,
the number's going to be a lot higher than zero.
I suspect it will be in the 10 to 20,000 range.
We won't know till we actually do it.
Okay.
Well,
let's,
let's eliminate,
let's go even over the alcohol.
Let's eliminate all things like violence and let's eliminate suicide.
And let's assume those people would have committed violence and committed
suicide.
Without it.
You're still looking at a giant number of people who drink themselves to death.
Thousands and thousands and thousands of people every year versus zero with
marijuana.
And you're aware,
I'm sure that correlation does not equal causation.
And that,
especially in a place like Colorado where you're dealing with cannabis,
something that stays in the system for many,
many weeks.
If you're testing people and they test positive for marijuana and they wind up
committing suicide or they wind up committing violence,
they don't even necessarily have to have been under the influence of it.
Well,
as you know,
there's,
when you test the blood,
you can test the both the active metabolite and the inactive metabolite THC.
So,
so the test,
when you do a blood test on somebody who's,
you know,
has committed suicide,
it's sophisticated enough to tease that out.
So there's a lot of people who have the active metabolite in their blood.
Um,
I agree.
Alcoholics,
they physically toxic substance.
Cannabis is a neurotoxin for a lot of people.
But in addition to,
you know,
the death,
there's also just the morbidity that's associated with alcohol.
I mean it ruins people's lives.
That ruins marriages.
Uh,
it leads to weight gain.
It leads to a lot of metabolic disturbances
for some people with marijuana too.
I think you could say some people,
especially weight gain at,
some people smoke a lot of pot and they get lazy and they started eating Cheetos
all day.
And,
and you could also say that with some people,
you know,
the waken bakers that you know,
seem to be wasting their lives away.
And that's like the stereotypical negative con.
You know,
when you,
when you're talking about a negative description of a marijuana user,
it's the waking Baker at the person who is high all the time.
You could absolutely said that could really ruin relationships.
You could absolutely say that it would ruin your job.
You could.
But again,
too,
you know,
we're using the term marijuana and really we should be using THC or high THC
when we're,
when we're saying that.
Okay.
Because you know,
people who use a high CBD every day as we know are most people listen to this
part of the CBD is non psychoactive,
does not get you high super benefits.
You know,
that can be extremely beneficial for,
you know,
a variety of different disorders that people have.
So,
you know,
we really need to be careful about using cannabis versus using THC because the
THC that can do that.
And to your point,
you know,
but you know,
you say like THC can cause the munchies and of course that's,
you know,
not good for someone who doesn't want to gain weight and just,
so people know the,
the way that it does do that is when she see attached it to the CB one receptor.
You had an increase in a hormone called Ghrelin and Ghrelin,
uh,
can actually induce hunger.
And that's why people get get the munchies.
But you know,
that is not necessarily a bad thing if you're someone who has cancer or if
you're someone you know,
who,
who's wasting away from,
from,
from a terrible illness.
You know,
sometimes,
you know,
having,
uh,
having the munchies is,
is definitely a good thing.
Um,
and I know,
you know,
a lot of people have said to me,
it's not available so you should probably not talk about as much,
but there is another cannabinoid called THCV.
So you know,
there's,
there's over a hundred cannabinoids in cannabis cheat seeing CD early,
two of them,
you know,
those are the main ones that people know about.
So THCV has been shown to actually reduce appetite.
So if we can get that out there in the market,
you know,
like we have with,
with CBD,
then we can almost seal,
eliminate or potentially,
you know,
substantially reduced the problem that people have with,
with,
with THC by using it,
uh,
with,
THCV darker.
And I have a question for you.
When people come into your practice,
did they,
do they want high CBD products or did they want to get intoxicated and no,
absolutely.
Absolutely.
Sure.
Of course.
Yeah.
So it's like if they don't need to go to him to get intoxicated.
So people,
so you're seeing a population that is genuinely interested in the health
benefits?
Absolutely,
because I mean if,
and I mean I'm glad that that,
uh,
that's legalized in Canada because it does make my job a little bit easier
because be like basically everyone who is coming to me now,
I know that they want to use it medically because if they want use it
recreationally,
I mean they just go to the store,
right?
Cause it's kind of a pain to get in to see me come in and have the discussion,
all that type of stuff.
So you know,
the people who see me now,
um,
you know,
they're all using it medically.
Um,
and then,
you know,
to answer your question though,
Alex,
almost all my patients,
as soon as they come in,
they say I don't want to get high.
I don't want to get high.
Like that's almost what everyone says.
So,
you know,
I think the word is out there that uh,
CBD is non psychoactive and it doesn't get you high.
And I think that a lot of people are really interested in that compound.
And you know,
if,
if the people didn't have the success that they've had over the past few years,
you know,
it wouldn't be as popular as it is.
So,
you know,
I think that,
um,
you know,
we do need to look at the scientific evidence,
but we do need to listen to others.
And the anecdotal evidence is,
you know,
something that,
that,
that we should consider because it is so strong.
Alex,
let me ask you this.
Why don't you consider it medicine when it has proven medical benefits?
It obviously can be medicine,
these narrow things
that the FDA has approved it for.
But as you know,
I'm sure when people talk about it as Madison,
when the,
the,
the ballot initiatives that have gotten it approved as a medicine have really
essentially deceive voters about the process.
Right?
So you go to,
you,
you go to a pot doctor,
you get an authorization.
That authorization essentially enables you to buy as much cannabis as you want
for the next year.
Most of the time in reality,
these doctors are not giving you a real medical examination.
They're saying to you,
Hey,
do you have pain?
Do you have anxiety?
Here's your authorization.
I don't think you should speak for every single about.
We don't do that.
Uh,
at my clinic.
And I know that,
you know,
a lot of the clinics in Canada anyway,
uh,
we definitely do not do that.
And,
uh,
you know,
we provide a lot of education at my clinic and there's other clinics in Canada
also provide education.
And,
and I,
and I imagine there's a spectrum,
but in the US,
this was a [inaudible].
And I spoke to advocates for my book.
I spoke to Rob Kampia,
who,
you know,
who ran the marijuana policy project for a long time,
um,
for the book.
And He,
and he acknowledged,
you know,
advocates knew that this was a backdoor route to legalization in the year.
I used to joke around about it.
My doctor said,
uh,
why did you do pot?
I said,
I'd get headaches.
He said,
when do you get headaches?
I said,
whenever I think about the fact that pot's illegal,
so he wrote me a prescription.
I mean,
let's be honest about it.
I'm not,
look,
I say in the book at the end,
I don't think this should be,
this substance should be legal.
I have favor decriminalization.
We're just sort of jumping ahead here.
But if it's gonna be legal,
I'd rather have it be legal for recreational use.
I'd rather that we don't pretend that THC high cannabis is a medicine and I'd
rather separate out.
Isn't that same?
Uh,
yeah.
But why are you saying don't pretend?
Because there's many medicines that have horrific side effects.
The medicine,
THC in regards to children's autism is pretty significant and well documented.
The epilepsy,
autism,
those are two huge things that happen with children that they've been shown to
severely mitigate with,
with edible marijuana.
So I have to push back on your a little bit.
CBD has been shown to reduce seizures in children with epilepsy.
It's,
it's improved for the anecdotal,
but I have a good friend who has a child who he uses it on and he showed it.
He mean it's been a game changer.
Yeah.
I mean I let just,
let me interrupt for a sec.
Slick.
I had a patient four or five years ago and uh,
she was 20 years old.
She couldn't drive a car because she had seizures.
Right.
So you can imagine being 20 years old,
not being able to drive a car,
all your friends are driving around.
So she uses a little bit of CBD,
not even every day.
She's never had a seizure saying,
okay,
and now she's able to drive her car.
But this is,
we're talking about CBD,
he's talking about THC.
And so you're talking about,
you're talking about a case.
Okay.
And,
and I'm not saying that your friend's situation didn't happen.
I'm not saying it's not real.
What I'm saying is that the reason we have clinical trials is because science,
the way you know whether a medicine works or not,
whether a chemical compound works,
whatever that company is,
the best way to know is you give it to two groups of you give,
you give the real medicine to one group of people and you'd give a placebo to
the other group and you see the changes in those two groups over time and you
find out whether you're not,
your theory about whether this works on a population level basis is real or not.
That's how that is at the core of medical science.
And we've basically thrown that rule out for THC.
Well that's not entirely correct.
You do know that there's were studies that were run during the Nixon
administration that showed the efficacy of marijuana and the safety of it,
and those were all squashed.
And you also,
I'm sure you know like when we're talking about marijuana,
you talking about something that's federally illegal,
it's not something that's easy that's easy to run these FDA studies on.
Yes,
and I do.
And I said at the end of the book,
I think we should drop that.
I think anybody who's got a legitimate interest in researching either THC or
cannabis or any of the compounds for a,
for a medical condition,
let them run phase one,
phase two,
phase three,
trust.
Let's see if this,
if this,
if this plant is good for these things,
I think that's a great idea.
But still,
why you saying that you don't think it is medicine when all these people find
benefit in it?
So,
so do you think they're getting it from just the CBD,
the minimal amount of CBD and marijuana?
No,
I think that again,
there,
there's been a lot of research done on THC and cannabis to see whether or not
those,
whether THC is a compound in weather,
smoke,
cannabis can treat these conditions.
And for the most part the studies have been negative.
The,
again,
there's negative in what way?
Meaning they haven't shown any actual,
uh,
like,
can you stay cite these studies there?
I mentioned that in my book.
Okay.
Well,
what,
what were the conclusions of these studies when you're saying that they're not
positive,
that they,
again,
that they didn't work,
that the drug didn't work on what?
On cancer,
on Alzheimer's disease,
on irritable bowel syndrome,
on.
So,
Alex,
I mean,
you know,
you're throwing a few different things out there and you know,
I appreciate the fact that we can't be going around.
You're saying things like,
you know,
cannabis cures cancer,
right?
But you know,
I,
uh,
you know,
and I've done done videos and this even like recently stating that,
but if you look at the research,
I mean specifically if you look at specific cancers,
uh,
there are studies that have shown that THC and CBD can help.
Like it's safe.
We're talking about breast cancer.
And I did a video on this recently.
You know,
if you are her two positive and you use cheap seeing CBD,
it came in fact,
uh,
reduce tumor size and it can reduce tumor growth.
Now,
if you have,
what does,
I'm sorry,
can I interrupt you?
What does that mean?
What does it subset of breast cancer,
right?
So,
um,
there's,
there's different types of breast cancer and that's just one subset of,
of breast cancer.
So there are other breast cancers which do not express cannabinoid receptors.
And you know,
I've seen a one study,
at least,
again,
it's only one study that show that when they gave cheats seat and animal model
and actually cause a proliferation of,
of tumor,
so at worse than them.
So,
you know,
I do agree with you Alex and the fact that,
we have to be careful about using terms like that,
but that just doesn't mean that we can't say that cannabis has no good for
cancer at all.
And I mean,
even in the National Academies of Science and Engineering Report,
you know,
they said that cancer was,
was great for chemotherapy induced nausea and vomiting.
Right.
So,
you know,
it's definitely a really good,
um,
you know,
medicine for,
a lot of different things.
And when we're talking about cheat,
see,
you know,
I,
uh,
I said earlier of course,
and we need to be careful about,
about THC,
but it definitely is still a medicine.
And you know,
to your point with regards to,
um,
you know,
not being a medicine say for something like Ptsd,
I come from it from a clinician's point of view,
so I'm not a researcher,
so I need to make sure that my patients are getting better.
It's very frustrating for me just to say to someone,
oh,
there's nothing I can do for you.
There's nothing I can do for,
you know,
so,
and I understand that,
you know,
doing something sometimes a is not going to be beneficial just because you're
doing something,
you have to do something that actually works.
But,
you know,
we do have epidemiological studies and we have,
uh,
other studies have shown that,
um,
you know,
when,
when patients are given a cannabis,
it can reduce their symptoms of PTSD.
There's also another study,
you know,
I don't use this drug too often,
call it called Nabilone.
So nabilone is just pure THC.
Nabilone was shown to reduce nightmares and people who have PTSD.
So,
you know,
it's just saying,
just so,
just because THC is psychoactive doesn't mean that it's not a medicine.
And just to keep on the topic of,
of PTSD.
Um,
in addition to that,
we've identified mechanisms of action.
Um,
I know,
and,
and there's one study,
I think Matt Hill was on the w was one of the authors of that study and he
noticed that and people who have PTSD,
there's an over 50% decrease in,
uh,
in levels of [inaudible].
So a nature naturally occurring,
which is,
which is a naturally occurring in the canal when it correct.
Um,
so you can get that through,
through exercise,
which is one excellent way to do it.
And you know,
and that's part of the,
uh,
the high that you get after you exercise.
But the other way that you can get it is by using cannabis.
So when,
when she,
she attaches to those CB one receptors,
you can get a release of an aunt of mine and,
uh,
it's kind of a dial can actually increase in animals by another mechanism of
action as well.
So,
you know,
there's different ways where we can,
raise a level of,
of deficiency.
So,
you know,
to me as a clinician,
if I have someone who is not doing very well,
you know,
they've been on a bunch of different medications,
I've identified that,
you know,
they have PTSD,
we have mechanisms of action,
we have studies.
And then again too,
you know,
don't discount my clinical experience.
Right?
I've been working for over five years,
you know,
just with,
uh,
just with cannabis.
I mean,
I do other medicines,
uh,
I use prescribed other medicines well,
but I've been doing cannabis medicine for over five years and you know,
there's a lot that,
that I've learned,
right?
So as much as I've learned,
you know,
through reading studies,
um,
and,
and through going to conferences and things like that,
you know,
for sure that the best resource as a clinician is to learn from your patients
and to hear what your patients tell me.
And you know,
the,
the things that my patients tell me is that THC is really effective for the
sleep at night.
And a lot of my patients,
especially my veteran patients,
have done really,
really well with,
with that.
And just,
just one further point too,
you know,
there was a,
I know it was,
it was a 2015 I believe it was.
There was a Meta analysis done.
I can pull it up if we need to that indicated that,
um,
you know,
a lot of medicines that are being used now for PTSD or just simply ineffective.
And the other thing too is that there's never been a medicine made specifically
for PTSD.
So all the medicines that people are using or for anxiety or for depression or
the for insomnia,
there are there for something else,
you know,
but when we look at like,
like a study that says people with PTSD have a lower level of [inaudible] and
then if you can increase that a level of Nando mind,
you know,
that's a good way to treat someone.
It doesn't matter whether it's a vitamin,
whether it's a hormone,
if as long as you are correcting a deficiency,
you're generally going to get excellent clinical results.
So let me,
let me sort of try to frame this a different way.
Um,
alcohol reduces blood pressure.
Okay.
Alcohol in,
you know,
generally tends to reduce cardiovascular events for people.
Um,
and during prohibition you could actually get a doctor's note for alcohol as a
medicine,
but alcohol is not a medicine.
Okay.
It's a recreational intoxicant.
It has some positive biological qualities and some negative biological
qualities.
And you know,
there was an argument I think in 10 to 20 years ago should we recommend that
people drink moderately one to two drinks a day.
And I think for the most part,
uh,
the medical profession has come down on the side of saying,
let's not do that.
There's too many noncardiac uh,
negative side effects with alcohol.
Just on that note though,
Alex in Canada right now,
I know the safe alcohol drinking guidelines are 14 drinks per week for men and
nine drinks a week for,
for women.
So,
you know,
basically to sue a day for men,
one and a half.
I see.
So you're saying,
okay,
like there's,
we don't see huge negative consequences at that level.
Okay.
That's,
that's fine.
That's a totally reasonable way to think about alcohol.
But what we're not saying that people was,
this is a medicine.
And I think that's where the confusion around really around high THC,
cannabis lies.
And I,
and again,
I don't mean to say that your friend's child is not benefiting.
I if you say,
uh,
he or she's benefiting.
I believe you.
What I'm saying is that that's not good enough for science.
We need randomized controlled trials.
And when those trials have been done and a lot of them have been done,
Joe,
a lot of them have been done.
They've almost unequivocally showing the cannabis doesn't work as a medicine,
the only actual place where beyond
these sort of very limited conditions like chemotherapy associated nausea,
which obviously is terrible for people who have it,
but isn't,
isn't that common?
Fortunately,
um,
cannabis has been shown to work as a pain reliever,
right?
Probably for the same reasons that alcohol works as a pain reliever sort of
dulls your awareness of your pain.
But even in that study or in those,
even in those studies,
they're mostly done against placebo,
not against opioids or against and ceds like Ibuprofen.
And there was a very big study for cannabis use in chronic pain over a multiyear
period,
uh,
in Australia that came out last year that showed that people who used cannabis
had a,
uh,
had more pain and use more opiates at the end of four years.
Then people who didn't.
So that,
so I would almost argue about what medicine is.
Yeah.
That study though had a lot of flaws in it.
And the other thing is that you need to look at someone who is already using
cannabis versus someone who is just using opioids.
So if someone is just using opioids and they want to come off cannabis,
um,
you know,
those Malcolm off opiates oil come off of opiates with cannabis,
multiple studies have shown that that that can be effective.
And that's not was the what was done in the Australian study that you're
referring to get a more naturalistic approach.
Right.
And,
and also too,
you know,
they,
they didn't have access to medical marijuana during that whole,
during that whole time.
Those are all self reported and they were getting it from,
you know,
recreational sources.
They weren't getting it from.
That's a big,
that's a big distinction though Alex.
Like they weren't getting it from a doctor who prescribed it.
Two of them,
they were there.
This was a self reported study and people are getting cannabis that you know,
they didn't really know what they were getting.
It wasn't a,
they weren't given any information from a doctor and that's why it's a medicine
Alex,
because you can tell someone,
you can tell a patient to take,
you know,
a certain amount of CBD every single day and when you take a certain amount
every single day,
it can reduce your symptoms and sometimes you need to increase that and
sometimes you need to decrease.
I think we should do that with all medicines.
We should be really clear about the distinction though,
between CBD and marijuana.
I mean we're,
we're really talking about the psychoactive version of it.
This is where,
where you're saying it's negative,
you're not,
you're not really arguing that CVD dr hardest talking about,
he's talking about using this as a medicine.
Certainly using the CVD.
He's titrating his patients,
he's monitoring them.
He's not writing them an authorization and saint come back in a year when it,
when it's up,
he's,
he's being a physician and you know,
and I think to the extent that marijuana is medicine,
we want people like him.
So you were admitted it's medicine.
No,
no,
no.
I don't admit that.
But you just said that.
I don't think I just said that
cause I think I said to the extent I'm trying to meet you,
I'll stop doing that.
Um,
uh,
but you know,
I think you said something else that was really interesting to me.
And this came up in the book too.
So you're a clinician,
you see sick people and you know,
it's funny,
my wife's a doctor too.
She's a psychiatrist.
That's how I sort of got hidden this.
But my wife is a forensic psychiatrist less than a clinician these days.
Her job is to evaluate people,
not so much to treat people.
Your job is to treat people.
You see sick people.
You want to help them feel better and you don't want to tell them,
there's nothing I can do for you.
There's nothing,
there's no hope for your pain.
There's no hope for your PTSD.
You want to help them.
And I totally get that.
But if you're an epidemiologist or a researcher who's,
who's trying to guide the,
you know,
the views on the medical practice of hundreds of thousands of doctors,
that's not good enough.
So you need to step back.
And I think,
I think you know,
this,
this epidemiologist in in Britain who I talked to,
he said to me,
he said,
you know,
I try not to draw conclusions because so often when I try to draw them,
I'm wrong.
Yeah.
And we need to be careful about that.
Right.
And,
and Alex,
you know,
one thing that was mentioned in your book,
um,
you know,
it was that,
you often,
you often cited the national academies of science and Engineering,
right?
But,
you know,
Ziva Cooper,
she's a member of that committee.
I mean,
she put out on our Twitter,
you can go to it.
It's from January 9th of 2019 she says in response in the recent year times
editorial on cannabis and as a committee member,
which by the way,
let me finish,
let me finish finish context of where it came from,
but this is someone you site,
Knight inside her excited,
you cited the report and she's a member of that,
all of that.
Okay.
So she said in response to the recent New York Times editorial on cannabis as a
committee member on NASA,
which is that committee and cannabinoids support,
we did not conclude that cannabis causes schizophrenia.
Then the drug alliance policy also said the report did not reach that
conclusion.
So those are pretty too authoritative.
Uh,
you know,
sources that are saying that,
in your book you didn't cite the research properly.
Right.
And then also they're saying that you left a lot out,
right?
They said that they have found an association between marijuana use and improved
cognitive outcomes and individuals with psychotic disorders that straight from
the same report.
And you know,
you failed to mention that.
Right?
So I think that,
you know,
when we're writing books or when we're giving out information,
you want to do it from a balanced approach and you don't want to just select,
you know,
the small amount of material that's just going to support your study.
You know,
we want to be truthful here.
Joe's show is always been very,
very truthful.
I mean,
Joe said,
right,
right at the beginning,
he doesn't think that,
uh,
that,
that cannabis is perfect for everyone and I don't think that either.
And in Canada we have really strict guidelines to follow.
Um,
you know,
basically no one prescribes chia seed,
anyone under the age of,
of 25 and you know,
all the conferences and stuff that I go to,
you know,
we don't really have too many discussions about that.
Like the doctors don't really have many,
you know,
much of a backlash about that.
Um,
so why is the distinction the age of 25 or they've decided that age?
So 25 basically is when you're,
you're fighting it.
Yeah,
it's fun.
It's,
it's,
it's fully developed.
And when you do look at the studies that do show an association between,
between cannabis and psychosis,
it's almost all in adolescence.
You know,
I think that Alex only has one study,
um,
and,
and his and his book that shows an extremely weak correlation between an adult
using cannabis and then developing any type of,
of mental illness later.
So,
you know,
25,
um,
is,
uh,
it's a good age,
but it's definitely a,
you know,
kind of a conservative ish,
ish age.
But,
you know,
it's,
it's something that,
that we follow.
And I think that,
you know,
we've done well with that in Canada.
So Alex,
why did you leave those conclusions?
I need to push back here.
Okay.
So the National Academy of Medicine report was drawn up by committee of 16
researchers.
Uh,
Ziva Cooper is the one who's publicly said the reports said this.
but I think that we should have,
uh,
emphasize that it also said this.
Okay.
What I,
what I wrote in that New York Times op Ed.
Uh,
what I wrote in the book is the plain language of the report and the plain
language is this cannabis use is associated with a risk of developing
schizophrenia and other psychosis.
The higher the use,
the greater the risk.
I may have a word or two wrong in that cause I'm doing it from memory,
but that's what it said.
And by the way,
the committee was very clear.
They separated a depression.
They said there we don't see as nearly as high risk for depression and
psychosis.
Uh,
even though,
by the way today,
just today,
a Jama Psychiatry,
the Journal of the American Medical Association Psychiatry,
uh,
put out a Meta analysis showing that cannabis is associated with depression and
suicidal thinking,
uh,
and actually suicide attempts at a three and a half to one rate.
This,
this literally was released today.
Um,
but to,
but to go back,
Ziva is one of 16 members of that committee.
So if you're going to talk,
if you're going to say that I misquoted the report,
which I did,
and I quoted an entirely accurately,
you need to say,
well,
why aren't the other 15 members of that committee saying that I misquoted.
Why is one person who works for the cannabis research initiative at Ucla,
which takes money from cannabis investors and users?
She's the one who said that I misquoted it.
Maybe she,
maybe we should ask why the other members of the committee are not speaking out
against my book.
Well,
I think that she was just one of the 16 members that that came out.
But you know,
you can't really expect a all the other members to,
to potentially,
you know,
comb out with that.
Why not?
Well,
some people did something wrong.
If I misquoted,
some people will and some people won't.
You know,
some people have,
you know,
the personality.
Some people have the platform,
like Ziva has a bunch of followers on our Twitter.
People know who she is.
You know,
a lot of people who do research actually are not into social media at all.
Like,
I don't think you were at all before you had your book.
Where are you?
Right.
Okay.
Yeah.
So you were an in a social media at all.
So,
you know,
I don't think that most people on that committee are,
are into social media.
You know,
Ziva just,
just happens to be,
and you know,
I even spoke to Ziva,
uh,
on the phone about this and you know,
and,
and she said that,
yeah,
you know,
I,
I don't,
uh,
that she agrees with everything that was in the report,
but she doesn't agree with your conclusions.
And to go back to what's quoted from the report,
but you're only quoting there,
but you're only quoting the parts that,
that site or soy that back your,
uh,
your opinions.
You're not quoting the entire part like you left.
Like,
why did you leave out the part that said they have found an association between
marijuana use and improved cognitive outcomes in individuals with psychotic
disorders.
Right.
So you're leaving out that,
why did you leave out that part?
If you can find me a psychiatrist who thinks that it's a good idea for somebody
with an active psychotic disorder.
That part,
why'd you leave out that part?
Well,
my book presents,
it makes a case,
right?
It makes a case that this is a big issue that we have not heard about at all and
the reasons that we haven't heard about it have a lot to do with the advocacy
community and the way they've presented this data for 25 years.
I wrote a book that is trying to break through a lot of noise,
so but still like to get a balanced approach.
Did you decide that you were only going to write about things that confirm your
belief that you held when you were writing this and what you were trying to push
and the title of the book and then in the conclusion of the book?
I think that's a really great question.
I say in the introduction to the book,
this book is not balanced.
There's not a lot of evidence in there.
If you want to fair,
if you want to read about how indicas and sativas strains are different.
And you know,
you're not going to read that in this book,
this,
but I will also,
I also want to say this,
I didn't come at this and I say this in the introduction of the book too,
as an anti cannabis crusader.
In fact,
when my wife said to me and she said to me over and over again in 2014 and 15
and 16,
these are the cases that I'm seeing.
These are the terrible things that people are doing after cannabis use.
I sort of said to her at first of all,
why do I always have to hear about this at the dinner table?
But,
uh,
but more importantly,
um,
you know,
why,
why is it that maybe these people were using other drugs?
Maybe,
maybe you're seeing a slice of the population that it's not representative.
Why is it that I should believe this?
This sounds like reefer madness to me.
And,
you know,
ultimately my wife,
who's the one who went to,
you know,
she actually,
as I was talking to doctor heart about this,
she grew up in,
uh,
in Newfoundland to,
and she went to the Memorial University of Newfoundland Medical School and she
went to Harvard and Columbia for her postgraduate training.
Uh,
you know,
eventually she got tired of me yapping back at her and she said,
why don't you go read the studies yourself?
And it was that,
that led me to read,
to write
this book because when I read the studies,
I could not believe the strength of the evidence Joe.
But you're still even in saying that you're,
you're still seeing positive results that you're,
you're excluding.
There's,
there's this one,
there's this one sentence.
I mean,
it's not just one sense,
but,
but there are a few sentences about how it may be that cannabis helps people is
positive because it helps,
it helps cognition in people with psychosis.
Maybe,
maybe not.
Wouldn't that qualify as medicine?
Uh,
not if it's,
no,
it wouldn't be approved as medicine.
If it's causing you to have other psychotic episodes.
These people have psychotic breaks and improves cognitive function and people
with psychotic breaks.
So,
so wouldn't that be something that you would prescribe to someone?
No.
Again,
you had need to think about how the FDA is looking at medicine.
No,
I understand the FDA's position.
Sure.
But I mean looking at it as medicine,
I mean if we could prove this through studies and through some sort of clinical
trials,
if it is improving your Iq two points on a test and I'm saying,
oh it is,
I'm not,
I think
I'd have to look at that.
I'm not sure.
But at the same time it's making you no,
no.
It's a few.
But it's time.
It's making you floridly psychotic.
You're not,
that's not medicine.
Well,
it's not necessarily.
At the same time,
one of the things that I read about schizophrenia and was that there's people
who are trying to make a correlation between marijuana use and schizophrenia.
But the problem with that correlation,
and what I read,
and maybe you could help me on this,
was that it's the exact same number that you find the general population.
It's essentially 1% of the general population has schizophrenia,
which is one out of 100 people.
And when you have marijuana users,
you see it's essentially that same number mirrored.
And so they're saying that a small number,
that's not true.
Hold on,
let me get in a small number of people.
What they were saying essentially in what I read was that marijuana use was
associated with the onset of schizophrenia.
They were disputing this in this study because they were saying,
but because then same number is mirrored in the general population.
Again,
correlation does not equal causation.
Right.
Dr Hard,
I think you got to tell him that's not true.
So tell me,
tell me what that means.
So traditionally,
yes,
when we look up the stats,
you'll see that you know the people who use cannabis versus the people who don't
use cannabis have very similar rates.
But you're getting to the exact rates.
So in the u s they say that,
uh,
the range,
if the for schizophrenia is between 0.25 to 0.64% globally,
they say it's 0.33 to 0.75%.
So,
you know,
right there,
it's,
you know,
apparently lower ain in the u s and the u s is,
is,
has the highest percentage of cannabis consumption in the world.
And the US also has a lot of people that are using high potency THC.
So,
you know,
I think that,
we really need to be,
be careful about throwing out stats like that because you know,
when you do look at the stats that we have,
it shows that even though,
uh,
you know,
the,
there's a lot of canvas use in the United States,
schizophrenia
rates have remained the same.
So I have to push back really hard on,
this is one of the great myths of legalization.
No one knows what the schizophrenia or psychosis rate in the is in the u s a lot
of people aren't treated,
people are treated people.
I'll get different diagnoses at different times and we have,
we have bad health care in this country and we have a lot of protections around
mental health.
In fact,
in 2017 than national institutes of mental health suddenly changed its estimate
for the percentage of people with schizophrenia in the US from 1.1% to 0.3% they
did it with no public notice.
And then this researcher said,
hey,
this is a miracle.
They just cured 2 million people with schizophrenia and the,
and then in response to that,
the director of the NIH said,
um,
well we actually don't know how many people have schizophrenia in the United
States.
Nobody knows,
nobody knows if the rate is increasing.
Nobody knows if it's decreasing.
The only countries where they can count noses on this with any accuracy.
Our northern Europe,
because they have good healthcare because they have slightly less protections
around sort of individual privacy and mental health privacy.
And so they are able to count cases and in Denmark and Finland,
which are,
which are the two places where they've actually done this research in the last
20 years,
they've shown increasing rates of schizophrenia between about 1995 and about
2010 and that goes side by side with increasing rates of cannabis use in the
nineties so the people who are saying that there's no evidence of population
wide increases in psychosis are just wrong.
That's just possible that there's other factors.
Environmental factors is a bunch of other different things.
But let me,
let me sit here on this.
We absolutely don't have the evidence at this point to say that cannabis use in
the u s is causing a population level increase in psychosis and schizophrenia,
which are,
oh by the way,
those are sort of different illnesses and we can,
we can talk about that too.
So we don't have the evidence to say there's a definite increase.
But what I'm saying is that what you have been told that there is no increase in
schizophrenia or psychosis rates in the US.
That's,
we don't know if that's true or not.
We just don't.
Me Ask you this,
there has been proven that there's an increase in marijuana use.
Is that correct?
Correct.
Absolutely.
How,
when,
when did the increase began and how,
what,
how,
what percentage increase?
So there was a,
there was an increase in the 90s and increase in use and in potency use sort of
bottomed out around 1991 and then there was sort of a flat bottomed out me and
it hasn't increased since 1950% since [inaudible] 92 that's a lot.
It's a lot.
It wasn't,
you expect a corresponding increase in schizophrenia.
If there was any sort of correlation,
hold on,
let me just,
let me walk you through.
Okay.
It bottomed out in the early nineties increased again,
increased in the 90s flattened out between about 2000 2006 and since then has
been going up again,
especially in let's say the last three,
four years.
And the other thing is that potency in the last 15 years has gone way up.
I don't think anybody would dispute that,
but okay.
Has Schizophrenia,
Ghana.
So what I'm saying to you is we don't know,
there is evidence,
there is,
there is now evidence on a population level basis in those other countries that
schizophrenia and psychosis has gone up.
And there's for the first time in 2017,
there's data showing that serious mental illness,
which is not the same as psychosis or schizophrenia in the u s doubled between
2008 and 2017 in the and the e in people aged 18 to 25 and those are the people
who are most likely to be using.
So for the first time,
there's actually evidence of what you're talking about,
which is a population wide increase.
Now again,
I'm not going to say I'm not going to,
can I get you to clarify?
It shouldn't say serious mental health.
So serious mental illness.
So this was defined.
Uh,
there's a study called the national survey on drug use and health.
It's done every year,
cover 70,000 people,
federal government funds it,
it's sort of the best data source we have on all this stuff.
Um,
it showed that,
and they're not counting cases either.
No.
Let me just be as clear as I can on this.
Nobody's counting schizophrenia and cases on a national or even state level
basis in the u s but you say to people,
did you have depression so bad that you couldn't get out of bed?
Did you,
you know,
were you hospitalized this year for psycho,
for,
for any inpatient psychiatric reason?
And,
and if you look at those numbers in 2008,
3.7%,
I remember maybe it's 3.8% of Americans,
18 to 25 reported,
uh,
at least one symptom.
So they were categorized as having serious mental illness that year in 2017 that
number was 7.5% so that's a double.
So again,
I am not going to say that proves that the increase in cannabis use has caused
this,
this population,
that's something phase.
But something bad has happened.
And if you look at kids 12 to 17,
interestingly,
they over that time period,
didn't have a big increase in cannabis use in general.
Teenagers are actually are pretty healthy now.
Although jewel in vaping may be undoing that and those kids didn't have a
population level increase in serious mental illness.
Can I stop
you for a second there because there's other factors.
One of the big one is,
you've all know Herati has a great book,
a 21 lessons for the 21st century.
I read that.
It's great.
And uh,
one of the things they talk about is the onset of social media.
Uh,
Jonathan Haidt talked about that as well and,
uh,
that the onset of social media,
it was actually more hate and then,
uh,
Herati but the,
Jonathan Haidt talks about it with young people.
Yeah.
I think coddling of the American mind.
I think that social media and the pressures of social media have led an
incredible amount of young people to,
uh,
serious mental distress and,
you know,
serious anxiety,
serious depression and suicide amongst young girls has increased some 50%
according to hate.
Um,
over the period of 2007,
two,
I think 2000.
And whenever his book was written,
uh,
and I,
they're directly
correlating that to the pressures of social media and to,
you know,
anonymous online bullying and all these different factors that are affecting
kids.
Yeah.
So I think that that could be considered a far more significant new,
uh,
form of,
of,
of distress to children and young people than even marijuana.
I think it does it twofold because I think that,
you know,
what makes people really depressed,
maybe more so than,
than anxious,
but definitely both is that when you compare yourself to someone else and you
know,
people,
you know,
obviously that we've done that,
all,
all humans have done that,
you know,
since since history began.
But now everything is online.
You can compare your life to everyone and it,
people are doing all the time.
And even worse than that,
and you know when we should talk about this too,
is that the income gap is getting,
is getting water.
So it's like people's lives,
not only are they getting,
you know,
better than than,
than other people's lives,
but it's what it now it's on,
it's on display.
So everyone can see it.
Whereas before,
you know,
maybe you wouldn't have seen it because it wasn't on social media,
but now it's on social media.
So you had this huge income gap that just keeps getting bigger and bigger and
bigger.
And then you have people going,
going on social media and they're comparing themselves and you're absolutely
right,
especially in that,
in that age population mean people under under the age of 30.
You know,
they're definitely,
uh,
you know,
they're being bullied online.
Like I see it every day in my office.
Like literally every day people are being bullied online and that's,
you know,
something that I never had to deal with growing up.
Um,
and you know,
a lot of kids do have,
do,
have to deal with that.
Just one more note to on,
on the,
uh,
since Colorado has,
has,
has legalized cannabis,
is this important for,
for,
for this,
uh,
this,
this subject in this topic?
Um,
they've actually seen marijuana rates decrease.
So it's important for people to know that,
you know,
just be knowing use or overall use or I use has gone up 10 years is flat overall
uses up.
Okay.
Yeah.
I'm talking about teen years that that's the category that we're talking about
under under 30.
Right.
So teen use,
you know,
would classify as part of that category.
So,
you know,
in Colorado we have seen a decrease because of the lack of,
because it's not illegal,
it's not as exciting to them.
Part of it for sure.
You know,
and I mean,
part of it like a one worry I had,
you know,
I haven't looked into the statistics yet.
It was,
you know,
when,
when you're growing up and,
uh,
when you're in high school,
you know,
if you want to be part of the cool crowd,
so to say,
what do you usually drink or you smoke pot,
you know,
that's what some people do.
Um,
I hope that that doesn't change because pot scene as medicine,
I hope that,
you know,
people don't,
you don't move on to or do something you'll harsher because they don't see pot
as,
as cool anymore.
My attached to it because it's legal.
Yeah.
I got to push back on it.
Okay,
cool.
Thanks please.
So everything you about social media sound,
you know it's sort of intuitively sounds correct,
right?
The problem is the data doesn't support this at all.
The data shows that teenagers another 12 to 17 those kids are healthier than
they were 10 or 20 or 30 years ago.
They drink less,
they smoke less,
they have sex later,
that fewer abortions,
they are healthier.
Okay.
And their mental health doesn't seem to have changed that much based on the Ns
D'you h data.
Okay.
The data shows a big change in kids 18 to 25 they go to college.
Something goes wrong for a lot of those kids,
at least in the last few years now.
But what do you mean when you're talking about suicide rates?
Suicide rates are there,
especially with young girls who are apparently more effected by social media.
They have gone up significantly since the rise of social media.
That is the big fan of people who are most likely a second more so than cannabis
use.
And then that's a fact.
So,
so you're,
so you're talking about a tiny,
tiny number of people who not only,
no,
it's not a tiny number,
50% increase of people that commit suicide.
There are young girls that people who commit suicide in the United States are
middle aged white men.
And that's,
wait a minute,
you're discounting these young girls that are committing suicide to fit your
statistics or to fit your conclusions?
No,
what I'm saying is that's a tiny,
tiny number,
but it's a 50% increase is not a tiny amount.
This is something that we can look up.
Well,
let's find out what the numbers are.
But because the,
when Jonathan Haidt was on the podcast and you discussed it,
I mean,
he showed this chart and it's an alarming increase directly correlating with the
increasing use of social media.
Sure.
I am probably,
I'm not such a pushback against that.
So it seems to be a factor.
What I'm,
when I'm pushing back against is the idea that kids 12 to 17 generally are less
healthy than they were 10 or 20 years.
And no one's saying they're less healthy.
You just said they're more health.
Yeah.
I'm saying they're more healthy.
Right,
and what we're saying that Kid's health has nothing to do with cardiovascular,
mentally healthy.
I mean they're less likely to use drugs.
They're less likely to have sex with them,
more likely to commit suicide.
That is a tiny,
tiny number.
What are you talking about?
If it's 50% increase,
that's a huge difference.
We should look up the number if we're gonna,
if we're going to it.
Look,
Jonathan hates work is like very well respected.
What,
what I'm saying to you is that there's a clear increase in psychological
distress in kids and young adults,
18 to 25 okay.
There's a clear increase and those are the people who are most likely to be
using cannabis,
people that are most likely on social media as well,
and that's a stressful period of your life.
How [inaudible] 17 you should live in at home like 18 to 25 then you've got to
go to university.
You got to deal with all these core seed,
the wound.
You can see the,
and I've said it at the beginning of the program that I think the marijuana with
some people is not beneficial and in fact could be negative,
but I don't understand why you're not willing to admit that social media has a
significant and unprecedented impact on young people that we've never seen
before.
I would totally agree with that,
but I don't think that you can say
based on the population level data that the impact is all negative.
It may be,
listen,
if maybe who is saying that the impact is all negative.
What we're saying is,
is it a 50% increase in suicide with young girls?
Right,
but that's huge.
Let me hear it.
Let me give you an example.
When you were 15 or I was 15 maybe you got really drunk,
right?
And wound up in a bathtub.
Like maybe kids today are less likely to do that because of social media because
they know it's going to be on Instagram forever.
I don't think that's true.
I don't think that's proven and announce.
I don't think there's anything that would point to that.
Well,
what I can tell you is proven is that kids,
today I'm talking about teens,
12 to 17 have less psychological distress by all these measures I'm talking
about.
Their actual behaviors are better or a better or worse.
That's a moral judgment,
but they're healthier than they were 10 or 20 or 30 years ago.
They're less likely to have sex.
They're less when they're 14 which I think most people say it's a good thing.
They're less likely to be drinking.
They're less likely to be smoking.
Those are good things.
Well,
less likely to
be drinking,
less likely to be smoking,
less likely to have sex does not correlate to positive mental outlook and less
suicide.
Well,
yes,
there's,
I agreed there.
We look.
Let's look at the numbers,
but depression and suicide are the very difficult things to measure,
right?
Depression,
well,
suicides,
actually suicides,
you're going to use it.
It's a hard number.
Depression is a is look at this spike
bottom numbers in females.
I mean this is what I'm saying,
that death rate,
first of all,
this is,
this is okay.
The death rate for girls age 15 to 19 is four per 100,000 Joe,
it's a 40 it's at a 40 year high.
Right.
So I mean you,
you'd be hard put to say that's a huge spike.
It was three per hundred thousand in 1975 and it's a little bit over four and
2015 that's not,
that's one case per 100,000 girls.
Yeah.
I don't know what,
I don't know what the actual facts are.
I'm looking at this right now.
The suicide rates for teens 15 to 19 years off is this is something that we'd
have to study and to,
uh,
have this discussion.
Giant spike for boys in the 1990s.
What the fuck is that?
About?
95 what
surprise,
if you put middle aged men on this chart,
you'd have to,
you'd have to blow out the ceiling.
Like the suicide crisis is unfortunately a crisis of age.
Yeah.
Okay.
I,
I would agree with that.
I think we actually talked about that yesterday with Andrew Yang that a suicide
amongst men in their 50s and then they start to feel useless and especially if
they lose their jobs.
Um,
but what Jonathan Haidt is pointing to is a direct correlation between social
media use,
depression and suicide amongst young girls.
Um,
thank you for finding,
what is it?
This is the article.
It's from his suicide rate for teen girls.
The highest it's been in 40 years is social media to blame.
Right?
So,
okay.
Um,
new data presented,
uh,
released Thursday by the Atlanta based Centers for Disease Control and
prevention suicide rates amongst 15 to 19 year old girls doubled between 2007
and 2015 reaching a 40 year high.
I would say that's significant.
Again,
I would,
and,
and it's obviously a terrible thing when anybody commits suicide,
but we're talking about two per 100,000.
It's five,
well went from two to four.
Okay.
That means for every 100,000 American girls in 2015,
five committed suicide.
That's not a very high number.
But I mean,
that's also someone who's pushed to the extreme of taking their life.
How many girls are experiencing severe depression but don't commit suicide.
That's the real factor because this is what hate directly connects to social
media.
Again,
the 50% increase,
you're talking about a relatively small number because not as many girls commit
suicide as men,
but still this could,
you're talking about,
you were talking about depression and you were talking about these significant
factors that would lead people to be,
to have poor mental health.
This could be a huge factor in this.
Right?
And I think that too,
it leads people to,
you know,
suicidal ideations and depression and anxiety.
Me,
right here we're just looking at CSI,
which is the worst possible,
which is very rare amongst girls periods or not or less.
Yes,
men,
men do commit suicide more than women do.
But you know,
we really have to be careful about that because,
you know,
again,
suicide is the aim.
That's the worst thing that could possibly happen.
So what about,
you know,
all,
all the,
uh,
all the things leading up to it,
you know,
are there people who are,
who don't commit suicide but you know,
suffer from terrible depression,
suffer from terrible anxiety software from terrible insomnia.
You know,
those people are not accounted for in that graph.
I agree.
And what I'm saying is that cannabis use has spiked in the United States in the
last 15 years.
And teens not withstanding,
we've seen a large degradation in a number of these social outcomes.
And now just today we have a Jama Psychiatry paper that looked at a bunch of
other studies that said cannabis use in teenagers is associated with depression,
suicidal ideation,
and suicide attempts in people once they get to 18 to 30.
Okay.
So again,
maybe a factor.
What's that?
It could possibly be a factor,
yes,
but it might,
it might also be that these kids are depressed because of social media and
they're using cannabis.
They're depressed because their friends died from opioid overdose.
There's a lot of potentials.
We are conceding the fact that,
you know,
you just said again,
that study was done on adolescents.
You know,
Joe and I have both concede it multiple times that,
you know,
we do not think high cheat.
See Cannabis is good for people in that age category.
But you know,
just,
uh,
just to back up just a little bit again,
you know,
I don't,
like I said earlier that,
you know,
I don't prescribe Cisi generally to anyone under the age of 25 and most other
doctors in Canada who don't.
But I think that we should be prescribing CBD to these kids.
Like a lot of those kids,
you know,
who have suicidal ideations,
depression,
I mean,
you know,
you could never do a study on it,
but you know,
how many of those kids wouldn't have committed
suicide or wouldn't be feeling this way if they were using CBD because we know
Ssri,
selective Serotonin reuptake inhibitors,
you know,
which are the most commonly prescribed a medication for depression and anxiety
even in,
in a,
in adolescents.
Um,
we know that they can increase suicidal ideations that's been shown.
I mean,
it's written right on,
right on the package.
So again,
like as a clinician you have to,
you know,
treat your patients.
If you're just treating people with something that's it's not effective or the
there that has,
you know,
horrible side effects,
you're going to look at other alternative treatments.
A lot of people have,
have,
have shown our,
sorry have had excellent results with CBD in that age category.
You know,
I've had had it done in my practice and lots of other,
you know,
physicians have had it done in,
in their practice.
So it's really important that when we're talking about teenagers and we were
talking about that study,
you're talking about high potency THC in adolescence.
That's where Joe and I both can see that,
you know,
THC is not a good medicine.
I
look if Gw Pharma or somebody else can,
can do a study with CBD and depression or some other cannabinoids and non
intoxicating cannabinoid in depression and get it approved for that,
that'd be great.
We need,
we need all the treatments for depression and for,
and boy do we need treatments for psychosis that we can get.
Um,
I totally agree with it and I'm really glad to hear you say you don't think that
adolescents should be using high potency or any hard drugs,
especially alcohol.
No.
And they,
and they should try this also stay away from the other medications.
I want to push back on this,
on the alcohol versus a cannabis for teens thing and I know that this is a
common feeling among you among people in Brooklyn and among people in La and
sort of right when I mean right thinking,
I mean,
you know,
sort of the general center left to left you everywhere is that cannabis is
better for teens than alcohol.
I totally disagree with that.
Canvas alcohol would no one's saying that.
I'm just saying alcohol's bad too.
Okay.
Then we agree.
But you know,
I mean I think you may have heard this right?
Oh,
I'd rather have my kids smoking pot,
my 16 year olds.
I think that's crazy.
You,
you have to really be careful with anything that's severely perturbs your sense
of reality when you're a young kid and you're trying to form your vision of the
world.
I think to unpack what we're saying here is that there is an increase in mental
health disorders amongst young kids that corresponds to the increased use of
social media and may correspond to the use of cannabis,
but that's not necessarily proven what we'd guarantee almost universally because
these kids are on social media and also to think much more likely that they're
on social media than use cannabis.
I think a lot of them use cannabis.
I don't think all of them,
all of them are on social media.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
I,
I think that,
you know,
almost every single kid these days,
these days has a cell phone and they have some type of social media account.
I'm worried about kids use it,
everything I'm worried about them using value them.
I'm worried about the end user
and using stimulants or Adderall and PROZAC.
I think,
I think psychiatrists give out add medicine much too frequently.
100% agree.
And I think that it has a severe impact on kids when they're trying to study for
tests,
when they're trying to take their sats,
when they're trying to get into a good college.
I know so many people that are on that shit.
I know so many people,
whether they're journalists,
I know Comedians,
I know a lot of fucking people are on Adderall.
Yes.
And you need to develop that kind of like toughness when you're young.
Like you shouldn't just be like,
you know,
14 years old and then you run into your first,
uh,
you know,
bit of trouble in your life and then you,
you,
you reach for a pill.
That's terrible.
That's a terrible coping,
coping mechanism.
So,
you know,
when you teach that to kids at a,
at an early age,
and when you tell them it's such a terrible thing to tell someone,
oh,
you're 14 years old,
you have major depressive disorder,
you're going to take this pill,
you need it for the rest of your life.
And that said to people all the time,
oh,
you have a bio chemical deficiency and this is what you need.
We need kids to be tougher.
Right?
So you need,
you need them to build up some,
some resiliency so that you know,
when they do go through hard times,
you know,
they have better coping mechanisms.
Like Joe Talks about diet and exercise all the time.
I talked about diet and exercise all the time and that's Kinda how I got my
start on on social media.
It is through diet and exercise.
Exercise is a big one for young.
I mean it was a gigantic factor for me personally.
When I was 15 years old,
I really got into martial arts and it changed my life,
changed my life by alleviating so much anxiety,
giving me so much more relaxed.
My parents talk about it to like there's to use theirs.
You before martial arts,
since you,
after martial arts.
Relatively young kids.
Yes.
And so do I.
And boy,
they love the devices.
I mean,
I mean we have to fight and we,
you know,
our kids,
the,
fortunately they're three and six at this point.
They don't have their own iPad or iPhone or any of that stuff,
but,
but you give it to them for five minutes.
It's like crack.
It's like,
yes,
you gotta tear down to their hand.
Oh yeah,
my,
my kid will just turn their shoulder when I try to get the iPad from her.
They were like,
no,
no.
One more.
It's crazy.
It's a little,
it made it very fun and exciting for them.
You know,
and look,
it's not entirely negative.
Like we have this,
uh,
this TV set up with this dance game that they play and they're sweating and
dancing and after it's over the giggling and laughing,
it's a massive alleviate or of,
of physical stress because it's like they're constantly got to follow this thing
and it's,
it's an exercise routine.
I mean,
they're really,
their cardio there,
their cardiovascular rate gets up and they really feel good afterwards.
So it's not entirely negative,
but it's mostly,
yes.
Yeah,
yeah.
If you have like a,
I dunno,
is that Nintendo we are or whatever it is.
Yeah.
You can do this little thing that scans it or you actually can use your phone
and if you hold a phone,
like I'll give them my phone.
My wife will give the other one the her phone.
And like the phone shows how you're moving.
It's very weird.
So like mimic this thing that the person on the screen is doing.
But that's one thing that could,
could be considered positive.
I think for the most part the real issue is social pressure and anxiety that
comes from kids talking shit about each other and they,
they push buttons,
they push buttons on each other because they know that they can like this.
They don't understand the consequences it has.
But you would get free from it when you went home.
You're not free from it ever.
Now these kids are waking up in the middle of the night and checking their
Twitter account and find it.
Their friends are talking shit about them,
whether it's on Facebook or whatever.
And this girl from school,
that fucking bitch and she commented on my youtube video,
this is what they're dealing with.
You know,
look at her with her fat face,
lol.
And then those little 12 year olds like,
oh that is,
that's a severe,
severe factor that no one had to consider
before.
Yeah.
And it makes you almost not want to go to school like this.
Kids who don't go to school because of that cause they don't want to have to
deal with,
you know,
someone said some,
I see it in my office all the time.
Someone said something to them last night on social media,
so I didn't go to school today because they don't want to have to face that.
Like that's something that you know,
my generation never ever had to face.
But I do.
I mean I do.
I think we're a little bit off topic here in terms of,
so we're talking about depression and anxiety.
We're talking about a factor.
Sure.
Could be considered as big if not bigger.
Social media does not,
was people that get psychotic.
I don't know about that.
Well I don't listen.
This is why I don't know about that.
Severe anxiety,
lack of sleep,
depression,
absolutely
correlated with altercations on social media.
Sure.
But social interactions that are severely,
they're correlated with poor mental health.
The good news is the brain is a relatively strong and power for some people.
But if you look at sort of,
it's not for everybody.
Some people that are in a really bad situation that of psychosis.
Okay.
Again,
it's less than 1% for schizophrenia,
which is the most severe version you had sort of,
you had bipolar disorder,
psychosis,
depressive psychosis,
other kinds of psychosis.
Maybe you get to about three to 4% of the population is going to be diagnosed
clinically with one of these illnesses over the course of their life.
So,
so okay,
on the one hand that's a,
that's a lot of people.
On the other hand,
most people are not going to get psychotic.
And most of the time if they do,
there's either a genetic component that's obvious cause psychosis and
schizophrenia often do run in families or there's an environmental component
that's,
that's pretty obvious.
I mean people can get psychotic,
they can get a brain tumor,
can make them psychotic,
they can,
you know,
it late in life,
they can get dementia that makes psychotic.
There's oftentimes a pretty clear,
uh,
organic cause.
Okay.
So when we're talking so,
so the brain is a relatively strong and healthy Oregon and it takes a lot to
break it.
And that's why,
I mean that's a bold state.
It is a bold statement,
but I would not,
I would not agree with that at all really.
You know?
Okay.
I mean I'm not saying that people don't get depressed,
takes a lot to break.
People are depressed.
All loans.
I'm talking about the title that that fucking antipsychotic medication was the
number one prescribed medication.
It's crazy.
Like people say to me,
you know,
people used to say,
hold on,
I'm on antidepressants,
I'm on,
I'm on antianxiety medication now people like I hear them at parties and stuff
saying like,
oh I'm on Seroquel.
I'm just thinking like,
well that person just tell a bunch of people that like throw on an anti
psychotic.
It's crazy.
It's weird that people don't know that Sarah Cohen at or below fire
anti-psychotics.
Right.
Cause they've been sort of marketed as outside the class when in reality they're
part of the class.
But I got to push back on you a little bit.
Sales numbers for those drugs.
Those are expensive drugs.
They're not the most prescribed drugs in the country.
Hold on.
Abilify was the most prescribed drug in the United States.
Should look that up.
We have looked that up.
We've talked about it on the podcast because it's insane.
That is insane.
And we do go to,
and this is a good time to,
to talk a little bit about genetics after we,
we,
we kind of look at this cause we can tease out a few things by looking at
genetics.
Anti-Psychotic Abilify is the biggest selling drug us to be a top seller drug
has to be expensive and also widely use.
Abilify is both.
It's the 14th most prescribed brand name medication,
so it's 40 stuff but fucking that's crazy.
All the people with actual diseases.
This is a 14th most prescribed brand name medication at retails for about $30 a
pill.
Well doctor,
I mean doctor can probably tell you this is getting prescribed as an ant on
antidepressant.
Fulsome people.
What that means though too is that equal are struggling man.
Like,
like life is hard for a lot of people.
Like very hard,
Alex.
I very difficult.
Okay,
so a lot of people need something sometimes at the end of the day or during the
day to help them get through the day.
Cannabis,
you know,
especially if the CBD component and also the THC component when used properly is
okay.
Like I tell people all the time I've made,
I've made social media posts about it that like,
you know,
if you need to use a little bit of cannabis at the end of the day just to help
you sleep,
man,
you're doing great and you're staying away from drugs and like,
you know,
prostitution,
gambling,
all these other brutal habits.
If you're doing all that,
they're like you're doing,
you're doing pretty good overall.
Right?
So gambling's not bad bro.
A little bit again,
what a bet on some fights you go.
It's absolutely,
by the way,
I think giving people handheld devices that,
that are inherently addictive,
where they can bet on sports every 15 seconds is a super bad idea.
I hundred percent agree.
Can talk about that too liquid.
You know,
it's one thing
it's benefited me with social media is my eyesight is going,
the god of the older,
I can't even read my Twitter feed.
I have fuck these people read it.
If I don't put my glasses,
I don't know what the fuck they're saying.
Oh my God,
it's so,
so,
so good.
People don't get depressed and anxious.
I'm swinging to say this is a different thing.
Okay.
I think we're,
we're,
we are dope though.
Discussing overall mental health.
I mean,
I'll look,
I'm saying this because I really think that this is something that I've,
I've made a big turn over the last few years,
uh,
with myself that I don't quick bathroom break gone.
I don't think marijuana is a safe,
as I used to think it is.
I used to think it was benign.
I really used to think there was no big deal.
But I have a friend that I discussed the other day who was a really confident
fucking muscular,
handsome man that never did anything and he took a marijuana edible to go to
sleep.
And for two weeks this guy was,
this is a different guy.
Not that I was talking to,
not not Rafi,
no,
a different guy.
He took it and he experienced suicidal thoughts and all these.
He had like severe consequences.
I think that the human beings,
we vary so much biologically that to just make this overall blanket statement,
what's good for you is good for me is irresponsible and I've been in a
responsible saying that well for one reason.
It's interesting,
one reason I think that alcohol is so widely accepted despite all the problems
it causes,
and again alcohol can certainly cause problems,
is that alcohol affects most people pretty much the same way.
You know if,
and you sorta know if what somebody looks like when they have one drink,
when they have five drinks,
you've got some trends that I've got some friends that get those juror belies
you ever see when people get sharp guys,
they're just gone.
They start talking crazy,
but you sort of know that and you sort of know how long it's going to take to
clear your body and you,
yes,
cannabis is so different.
It's really complicated drug and it does affect different people in different
ways.
And also the tolerance has changed radically.
So you know,
people say,
well two and a half milligrams of Thc,
you vape it.
That's like one drink for somebody who you know who doesn't use.
But then if you're on,
if you're a tolerant user,
you can use 200 milligrams in a day.
That's 80 drinks.
Yeah,
it's a weird drug.
And then there's the issue of eating it.
When you eat it,
your body produces something called 11 hydroxy metabolite.
It's a far more psychoactive.
You were all along for the ride when that happens.
Yes you are.
Yes.
And it can take days for it to get out of your system.
I know many people have eaten marijuana edibles and then they call me up the
next day like,
dude,
I'm still hot.
Yeah,
it's true.
So,
so,
so I think,
I think the legalization community has sort of said for years like,
oh,
there's basically no downsides to this.
There's only upsides.
The cops will bus smokers,
there'll be tax revenue.
All of these people have a way to get high.
That's clearly safer than alcohol.
And unfortunately that's just not true.
I think you're right.
And I think the issue that people,
from what I've read are
having with your book are people that are marijuana advocates and think that
your position is unbalanced and that you've ignored the positive aspects of THC
in terms of like what he was talking about,
cognitive benefits for people with psychotic episodes and that you are only
focusing on the negative.
I'll plead guilty to them cause I think that for 20 years people have only heard
the positive.
Right?
I think that's a,
I think that's also,
I'll plead guilty to up myself cause I think that I've only been discussing the
positives and one of the things that I've tried very hard to do and one of the
things I've learned how to do from doing this podcast and experience and
criticism and communicating with a bunch of different people with a lot of
different viewpoints is examine my own positions and try to figure out,
am I coming at this from a truly balanced position or am I trying to support a
conclusion that I started out with?
And I'm trying to,
you know,
somehow or another backup my own work or back up my own,
just my own statements and,
and,
and sort of prop them up instead of being really honest and objective.
And it's very difficult to do.
I wrote a book called Tell Your children the truth about marijuana,
mental illness and violence.
I don't think you can,
you can think that that book is going to be a compendium of the pros and cons
of,
well,
if you want to tell your children the truth though,
you really do want to tell them the pros and cons.
And then you did indicate,
Alex,
you said,
you know,
we should tell people the truth in the book,
right?
So,
you know,
I think that when you're telling and you're saying that,
that you're telling the truth,
and Alex,
I'm agreeing with you that you're telling part of the truth,
right?
But part of the truth is,
you know,
a little bit deceiving and deceptive in some ways,
right?
You want to tell the whole truth when you tell the whole truth,
then you give the whole story and then people can actually make you know,
a good informed decision based upon that.
Like if people are going to just read one part of the story,
then of course they're going to make a decision just based upon that one part.
They're not going to make an informed decision based upon all of the pots and
because of that,
people are going to make you know,
some very poor choices.
I completely agree with that,
but to me the last 20 years have been an exercise in the other side,
in the legalization side,
doing a very,
very good job talking up its arguments and essentially there's,
there's almost nobody on the other side.
There's this one guy who's got on Jeff sessions,
he had the fucking goddamn attorney general telling people that good people
don't smoke marijuana and that's literally a quote that says,
and thank God that little more on,
it's not in an opposite,
I'm more,
but that's,
that's a terrible thing to say.
People don't smoke marijuana.
I,
there's a lot of wonderful people who smoke marijuana.
That's just not true.
And by the way,
I think this is a personal choice,
okay?
Especially for adults and,
and you can make bad personal choices.
You Go,
look,
I play cards.
I love to play poker.
Um,
said that on this trip to La,
I didn't get to go to a poker room,
but you can go into casino and you can see people who've lost change your flight
places close by.
I don't incur Ari.
You used to make a living doing that and struggling with
comedy.
Don't encourage me,
but you can go to a casino and see people who've lost their houses.
It doesn't mean that gambling should be illegal.
It also means that there's less and more dangerous forms.
That device in your hand where you can bet on what the next pitch is going to
be.
If it's going to be a ball or strike.
That's more dangerous than my having to drive to the commerce and play there.
And 100% or 98% THC that an 18 year old vapes is a lot more dangerous than a 5%
CBD,
15% THC product that doctor heart might suggest is patient uses once a night to
go to sleep.
But that,
but that's the message that,
you know,
we should be putting out there,
right?
We shouldn't just be,
you know,
focusing on one side of the story.
Like that part,
you know,
should also be included in the book and like,
you're a book.
Um,
you know,
in some ways has made me rethink the way that I write.
You know,
because my first book,
uh,
was coauthor with Jeremy Costs and call friendly fire.
You know,
my second book that I'm writing now is called cannabis for PTG.
So is how to transform posttraumatic stress into posttraumatic growth.
Right?
Because I feel that,
you know,
we all know examples of people that have you encountered really difficult
obstacles in their life and some people have,
you know,
succumb to that stress and they've gone down the wrong path kind of thing.
And then other people have used that stress to their advantage and they've
actually become better because of it.
And you know,
um,
CBD and Thc can both help facilitate that process.
You know,
when you're looking at someone like a veteran,
for example,
you're the hallmark of someone with whose PTSD is someone who doesn't leave
their home and they can't sleep at night.
So like when I see a vet in my office,
a lot of the times they'll be leaving their home like five to 10 days a month,
right?
So when you give them CBD,
and this is really important for people to understand,
CBD has been shown to decrease learned fear.
That's incredible,
right?
So,
um,
if you can get people outside of their home,
because I'm not talking about,
again,
you know,
someone who's,
I'm too nervous to like go to,
uh,
you know,
the bar with like the friends or something like that.
I'm talking to people who were like,
you know,
it was difficult for them to go to the grocery store,
just like pick up a few things.
So,
you know,
those are the type of people that I see in my practice of CBD is really
excellent for that.
Then when you look at,
you know,
the,
the nighttime component,
um,
you know,
THC again is excellent for reducing nightmares.
That's been shown in studies and it was even shown with one pharmaceutical drug
nabilone.
Again,
I don't really use nabilone very much because it's only one cannabinoid and I do
believe in,
in,
in the entourage effect and using all of the cannabinoids.
So I don't use it that much.
But that shows that she,
she came reduced nightmares and you know,
if you have,
you have,
if you have PTSD,
I mean if you talk to someone who has PTSD,
and again this is,
this comes from a clinician's point of view,
they will tell you,
I will try anything.
And that's the same way when you get with like,
you know,
the parents of,
of,
of kids who have seizures all day.
Nobody
wants to see that you like and like,
and like Alex,
you know,
if your kids,
ever started getting,
getting seizures,
which you know,
I hope,
I hope they don't because it's,
it's terrible.
You know what,
what it can do to people.
But if that ever happened,
you know,
I would hope that you would consider,
CBD as a potential treatment option.
He's not against it.
I think we have to be really clear as a distinction.
Like CBD,
you're not against you at all and I don't,
I don't think anybody is.
I think no one really is arguing except maybe the federal government in certain
levels is arguing against CBD.
That's probably some pushback from the pharmaceutical industry.
The reality is CBD is proven to be,
at least as far as I've read,
very safe and very effective for a bunch of different disorders,
especially those that are about reducing and have something to do with
inflammation or seizures.
Yeah.
One of my good friends,
his son has developed seizures and CBD knocked it out,
just killed it,
killed it on time.
This is very recently,
you know,
you're somebody who's a,
who's a cannabis user,
you obviously know a lot of users.
Why do you think it is it people,
you know,
in legal states where they can really express a preference,
they can go into a dispensary,
know exactly what they're buying.
Why is it that they want such high potency THC product?
Because they get used to it.
Um,
you,
your tolerance develops,
it builds up,
you know,
every year we do this thing called sober October.
Well,
we don't do any no drinking,
no,
no pot.
And we do do some sort of crazy challenge,
uh,
me and three of my buddies and,
when we do it,
uh,
what,
it's very interesting how your tolerance is radically reduced.
Like,
I'll smoke pot at the end of that month and I'm like,
Holy Shit.
Like,
I don't even know what I'm talking about in the mid sentence and I'm just
blitzkrieg.
Whereas,
you know,
now like,
uh,
I smoked a little weed last night,
did some stand up,
had a great old time.
There was no,
no issues with it at all.
But I'm used to it.
And if the weed that I smoked last night,
I assume you don't smoke.
I do not.
Okay.
If you and me were together last night and I gave you a hit of my joint,
you'd beat still there in the corner,
in the fetal position going,
what in the fuck is going on?
Because the marijuana is ridiculously powerful.
But once you're accustomed to it,
once your body acclimates,
it's really not that big of a deal.
The problem is,
uh,
you,
you're dealing with a lot of habitual daily users.
And for those people,
like my friend Joey Diaz,
if there's a video of him giving this a other comedian,
uh,
w how many milligrams of those stars with death?
Oh,
like when we give Owen,
what did he give all them?
I think just one.
He ruined his life would have been about 200 to 250,
two 54 and went out.
The,
Joey made a video,
but the day it changed Owen's life,
like literally fucked the guy's head up.
Like he went outside and he vanished.
He's gone.
That's cannabis.
Like,
oh,
well I think,
I think there's a real argument to be made.
It's particularly with him.
Well it's like it was going to make two points on that.
So you definitely came develop a tolerance seal and I tell people all the time,
try and take at one three week break.
Um,
but the evidence does show that if you stop for four weeks,
generally all your sectors return and will be like you've never used cannabis
before.
She saw it.
And that's even with people who are really,
really heavy users.
I can go back and get the study.
Um,
but I mean these people are you using,
I'm pretty sure it was like close like seven joints a day.
Well really heavy users and snoop Dogg's a good example of that.
My friend Tony Hinchcliffe is good buddies with snoop Dogg and he said Snoop
Dogg just smokes all day and he just like,
he's always high and you know,
they're like,
well what do you do when you're not high?
He's like,
what?
I'm never not high.
So everything he does,
he is high as fuck.
Everything he does.
Like for that guy,
it's not that big of a deal.
And for the way he lives his life,
like he's just a relaxed,
easy going guy.
It's no problem.
You can be high all day and live his life and he's obviously wildly successful
with this strategy.
Yeah.
Worldly success.
The second point I was gonna I was going to make on that too though was there
does not appear to be any tolerance at the CB two receptors.
So cheesy attaches to the CB one receptor and that's,
and that's where we know we can get tolerance.
You know,
some people,
you know,
they,
they have some pain that use some TFC and sometimes they need a little bit more.
Same sometimes asleep,
you know,
the use TC,
it'll work and then we'll stop working with CBD to,
we haven't seen that.
Meaning like the people who,
uh,
you know,
get,
get seizure control.
Generally they don't need to increase the dose.
Like the girl I was talking about earlier,
um,
you know,
at first described,
I think when she was 20,
when she was about in 20,
she's 25 now.
She's never increased her dose.
I mean,
she's just used the same amount to CBD for the last five years.
Medicine.
Right.
Like it works.
I think we should really stop talking about CBD.
I just wanted to make a note on the,
uh,
on the tolerance of the CPU on,
I just wanted to make a note that CBT there doesn't appear to be tolerance.
And so it's just,
there's just such a significant impact,
um,
when,
when it comes to especially edible THC,
uh,
it's a,
there's a significant impact on people's state of mind and it's not always good.
That's just a fact.
We,
I mean,
we were talking about this when,
when you were were out,
but you know,
that's why I,
so I had an interview.
I was that guy who was doing the radio interview on the Slo from,
from DC to New York last month.
And,
uh,
this woman came in and it was Baltimore.
She sat down next to me and I finished the interview and she said,
she said I couldn't help overhearing.
I thought,
oh,
Jesus.
Like she's,
she's,
she's a pothead or she's just annoyed that I was doing this.
But no,
she said,
you know,
I was in Seattle last month.
She's,
this woman was in her early thirties.
She was a lawyer,
uh,
married.
She said,
and a friend of mine said to me,
let's,
let's have,
let's do an edible.
Uh,
she said,
I took it,
we bought a small dose.
We asked them for a small dose.
I took half of it.
So I think she took like five milligrams if that.
And she said,
she said,
I got so paranoid.
She said I couldn't sleep all night.
Fortunately,
my friend took and didn't have any problem and sort of watched over me,
but she said,
the worst part was it took me weeks,
weeks for the anxiety to faith.
And I said,
I said,
do you have,
do you have a history of mental health problems?
And she said,
no,
I don't.
She said,
she said,
and I'd used,
you know,
I'd smoked in college and,
uh,
but this was just a totally different experience.
There's a big problem with education,
a big problem with the education that edible marijuana,
as we talked about before,
I think you were in the bathroom,
the 11 hydroxy metabolite as it's processed by the liver,
it's a radically different truck,
radically different and it's really a psychedelic and in a very,
for me personally,
edible marijuana and flotation tanks,
I might as well be taking a fucking bucket of acid
crazy God experience.
Now I personally enjoy being paranoid and I know this sounds crazy,
but I think with me it gives me an,
I think I live a pretty blessed life and I like,
I liked the feeling of paranoia because it allows me to explore maybe some area
like maybe a specific paranoia that you have.
It's a freak out man.
I think I have maybe an abundance of confidence.
Maybe I have too much,
right?
Maybe I'm too successful.
What I like about the paranoia that comes with edible marijuana is it allows me
to check myself.
It allows me to put myself,
examine all of my behavior in the darkest recesses of my mind and my thoughts
and and gives me a purse.
And it makes me a nicer person might go just a little tiny,
just like the other psychedelics were thing.
It just,
it gives you just a little knock stone,
an eagle,
just little,
I mean some people use it and like at the end of the day and then you know like,
like Joe said,
I think it makes you reflect sometimes better and more objectively.
Meaning that like,
you know,
maybe you hadn't encountered with someone early on the day and then you know
late at night or you toke up a bit and you're like,
oh man,
I probably should have done things a little bit different.
You know,
like that happens to people all,
all the time.
It just,
it forces you to reflect in a different state and sometimes when you reflect in
that state,
you come up with thoughts that,
that you just want to come up with before.
Yeah,
like my patients say to me all the time,
like it just kind of breaks this negative state that I have.
I'm just able to,
to,
to break out of a negative state and think logically,
you know,
people say that to me all the time,
but let's see.
You're,
to me,
you're talking about something different and it works for you,
right?
Your,
your paranoia is,
it sounds more,
almost existential.
It's how can I be a better person?
What am I doing wrong in my life?
It's not my wife is poisoning me.
No,
no,
no joke.
This is funny.
And your schizophrenia,
yeah,
no,
I used to have or you know,
or the cops aren't going to bust through the fucking door then shoot me.
Yes.
It's a different thing.
And that's why,
that's why Marin marijuana drives this extreme violence in some people.
Or those people need to get their fucking shit together when that's possible
too.
Well,
I mean,
they may need,
aliens aren't really common bro,
but they may need to be intervened before and,
and to Joe's point though,
they have shown in studies that if you make an intervention other outside of the
psychotic symptoms,
you can actually reduce the incidents of violence.
And also too,
I think it's,
you know,
a good point I was going to mention earlier to bring up genetics because we are
teasing out genetics for people and we are discovering that certain people do
have certain genetics that do predispose them to certain cannabis disorders.
Right?
So,
you know,
I'm involved with,
with,
with the company that's doing that right now and we're trying to create,
um,
cannabis genetic tests for people.
Right.
And there's three genes that we've identified so far,
you know,
one of them is that Amy p k 14 geno type and that has been shown to be
associated with,
um,
a,
a deficit and brain volume when you do use cannabis.
And then there's two other genes,
the akt one and the ca d and M to Geno type.
You know,
both of those have also been shown to be associated with cannabis.
But again,
you know,
how many people have them?
Um,
BMAP K 14 it's roughly about 8% is what we're seeing.
The akt one is around 4% and the ca DM two is around,
is around 5%.
So there's so many that up that's almost 20% of the population,
but,
but we're seeing,
but if we can identify,
um,
I love that stuff lines me.
Yeah,
it's wicked.
Um,
so if we can identify,
you know,
the,
the people who are at risk,
then we can maybe potentially,
you know,
you use the medicine in a way where only the people who don't have these
genetics are using the medicine.
And then,
you know,
for the people who do have these genetics,
they stick mostly to CBD.
I just think you know,
that that's a better approach then,
you know,
just,
just kind of prohibiting cannabis are saying that,
you know,
we shouldn't,
we shouldn't use it at all,
are saying that it's not medicine.
I think that it should be held to the same standard as any other medicine.
And I think that if we had an incredible medicine that worked for some people
and that didn't work for others than what we would do is we would try to figure
out why.
And you know,
I've been doing that.
My companies have been doing that.
It's called a net life.
You know,
full disclosure,
I am on the board,
um,
and that life t.com and you know,
and when we use these different,
these different strategies,
then we can actually reduce the overall harm.
And that should be another thing that we can add into the mix because for sure
there's people who are definitely more predisposed to mental illness and
definitely more predisposed to,
to a psychosis.
I mean,
they're,
there do seem to be some people who just,
it breaks really.
And I'm not sure
why.
I mean,
again,
it's probably genetic.
There's,
yeah,
I think it's you,
you mentioned,
uh,
you know,
your,
your friend who's,
uh,
who's child has autism and,
and you said,
well,
you know,
I,
if that,
if that were my child,
of course I would want to do anything possible.
But I have to tell you in the last month since the book came out,
I've heard the other side of this.
Okay.
I've heard from so many parents whose children and in many cases,
high functioning children,
college graduates.
Because by the way,
those are the people you know,
read the book or heard about the book.
And,
and who have the resources to stay involved with their kids when they have these
terrible breaks.
Who,
who,
who've gone completely off the rails.
And the worst story that I've heard so far,
um,
came from a woman in Connecticut whose son graduated from high referred,
you know,
it's a college in the east and um,
sounds like a really good guy.
He wanted to,
Eh,
you know,
teach disadvantaged kids.
He had a girlfriend who was going to met or it was a premed trying to go to med
school.
They moved to New Mexico and for some reason the guy decided to start smoking.
And this was 2012 and within a few months he lost everything.
Okay.
The girlfriend had left,
he lost his job.
He had his first inpatient hospitalization.
Now this is a family with money.
Okay,
this is Connecticut's a bourbon.
Uh,
and they have spent the last six years trying to save their son and they have
failed that.
She told me that they've spent more than half a million dollars.
He was hospitalized at Harvard,
you know,
he,
he had the best treatment.
None of it's made a difference to him and what is sort of the symptoms.
And so,
so,
so he's,
he's completely schizophrenia now and he's completely paranoid and he believes,
and this is the,
this is the,
so he,
his,
his girlfriend is long gone,
but she's tried CBD.
Uh,
that's a good question.
I think he's continued to use cannabis.
I don't know if he's used CBD,
but let me,
let me just tell you where he is now.
Okay.
So he's one of these guys who has a really bad delusion.
His delusion is that his girlfriend has died and been replaced by a robot.
So that's the kind of delusion that leads you to kill people.
And so,
and so this guy has been now hospital as 17 times.
He's,
he's gone.
he's on the streets of Houston.
She doesn't know where he is.
And I'll tell you,
you know,
you read beautiful boy,
you see the movie and you think,
well,
the one I'm not familiar.
Oh,
beautiful boys about,
um,
a beautiful mind,
isn't it?
No,
no.
Beautiful boy is the,
is a book that came out I think a couple of years ago and got turned into a
movie.
You should have him on a nic Sheff and David Sheff,
um,
father and son and the son became a meth addict and essentially almost died.
Uh,
he,
they,
he started smoking cannabis when he was 12,
and within a couple of years it had all gone completely downhill for him.
Um,
I'm surprised it's a,
it's a pretty popular book,
but anyway,
have you heard of it?
Um,
Jamie and I've heard of the movie.
Yeah.
Um,
so,
so you think,
well,
okay.
The worst thing that can happen,
you as a parent,
the worst thing is your,
your child becomes an opioid addict and you wait for the call that he overdosed
and died.
It turns out that that's the second worst.
The worst thing that can happen is your son,
the college graduate,
the want to be,
do good or becomes a schizophrenia living on the streets and then you're waiting
for the call that he killed himself or he killed somebody else.
And so my,
my,
you know,
my view of this is in a couple more years probably,
I mean,
this book has taken over my life obviously,
but in a couple of years I'm going to be back to writing novels.
I'm going to be,
you know,
I'll still,
but this will still be part of my life.
But this woman,
these parents,
they are going to spend their lives trying to destroy the cannabis industry and
that is real.
Well,
I think,
uh,
that would be a foolish thing to do.
Uh,
but I think there is a real possibility that some people who have a tendency to
schizophrenia could be triggered by cannabis.
I don't,
there's no need to know Ashton about that,
but I think it's also possible that guy would've gotten schizophrenia anyway.
Look,
it's possible.
But he was sort of at the outer edge of the window and he had no other,
the other edge of the window and watch for boys.
It's sort of 17 to 2124 was he showing any issues before it all according to
her?
I mean this is from her,
so she's the mother,
but I'm sure she'd be the one who knows the most.
There are people though too,
who just kind of have a decline with or without cannabis and you do here.
Sometimes it's schizophrenia just to break up.
They just can't handle life.
I mean,
I know people,
you know that we've gotten a medical and stuff,
have gone to medical school and then one semester they just can't handle the
course load and then their life just goes to shit.
They drop out of school.
No one ever hears from them again.
They don't read,
you know,
get,
get back into school.
That's it.
But that,
that does happen all the time.
That speaks to the fragility of the human mind.
You know,
it's a terrible,
it is to have,
it has and it affects a certain percentage of the population regardless of
cannabis use.
Um,
there's a lot of people out there that have schizophrenia that I've never used
cannabis ever and they've gone completely off off the edge.
Um,
I don't know if you can necessarily blame cannabis for that.
Uh,
and it would be really interesting to find out if there was some form of a
treatment,
like you were saying with CBD that uh,
could counteract that or it has been shown in early stage studies to have some
moderate impact on psychosis.
I don't think from the,
the numbers that I've seen suggest it really isn't that strong as an anti
psychotic.
But I do think that if I were a researcher and schizophrenia,
I would be looking at the endocannabinoid system.
Yeah,
you have to look at this.
Again,
I look at it from a clinical perspective.
Like the Anti psychotics that we have out there are not good,
terrible.
They have terrible side effects and most of them do have some initial benefit
benefit.
But after two to three years,
it was almost no benefit one way.
And they have a,
as you said,
really bad side effects,
weight gain,
metabolic disturbances,
like people want to get off of them.
So if you have something like CBD that doesn't have any of those side effects,
of course as a clinician,
you're going to want to try it,
right.
Because you know that
the other tools that you have are not really that effective.
Right.
So,
you know,
CBD can,
should,
should definitely be,
um,
you know,
utilize for people who have,
who have psychosis and schizophrenia.
Well,
I think,
you know,
we talked about life changes,
like things that happen badly and you live losing your job,
losing your girlfriend.
Um,
deaths in the family can,
can trigger these breaks,
but some folks,
but psychedelic drugs can as well.
I mean,
it's a fact for some people.
Psychedelic drugs have tremendous benefits for PTSD.
Uh,
quitting alcohol.
Quitting a hard drugs is a lot of people that have used mushrooms.
Mtma for PTSD is a huge thing that maps is studying right now.
But you can't deny that there's other people and well documented that have taken
LSD,
that have taken psilocybin and taking them in large doses and then gone and
never recovered.
And that's why too,
I forget who it was.
Maybe it was,
um,
Mckenna who is on,
and you guys were saying that like,
you know,
we need to use,
um,
psychedelic medicines,
but we need to use them properly.
And that's the same way with,
with,
uh,
with cannabis as well.
I considered cannabis a psychedelic,
particularly when you eat it.
Absolutely it is,
it is a mild psychedelic and you know,
so,
so there's risks and benefits to that.
And you know,
we need to tease out the rest and tease out the benefits and making sure that
people are,
we make,
but Alex,
we need to make sure that people are informed and they get the entire picture.
Right.
So,
you know,
does your book have some truth in it?
Yes,
of course it does.
But does it tell the whole truth?
Absolutely not.
Right.
And that's the message that,
you know,
I think people should be hearing,
people shouldn't be hearing just part of the truth.
They should be hearing the whole truth.
And again,
you know,
like in your book,
like you compared,
you know,
the,
the met Mexico and in India,
right.
And you know,
I talked to,
to German Lopez on the phone about this and you know,
who talked to Isaac Cam shows,
right?
And he said,
so,
so Isaac came post,
you know,
he's the guy who,
who basically,
you know,
it was told the story of how,
um,
how in Mexico,
you know,
people were blaming,
uh,
marijuana.
People were blaming,
um,
Ma marijuana on causing psychosis during kind of like the early 19 hundreds.
Um,
and then there was some evidence as well in India at that time.
So I was kind of made the connection,
you know,
9,000 miles apart.
You know,
they're both saying the same thing,
but you know,
he said that,
you know,
you did misinterpret the evidence on it.
Right.
And,
and in German told me that on the,
on the phone and I mean,
all the cannabis that was used in Mexico at that time was in,
you know,
really marginalized environments.
And then when you look at,
um,
the India study,
you know,
they,
and I know that you addressed this in your book out because I did read your
book,
so I bought your book.
So,
you know,
in some ways I did get support here.
Um,
so I,
uh,
I read your book and like I said,
you know,
you did address in the part on India that um,
yeah,
you know,
some of the,
uh,
report was wrong,
but I mean the fact is that all,
almost a lot of those cases in India were,
were actually attributed to alcohol or opiates or other things.
And then the other thing in,
in,
uh,
in Mexico is that it was in those environments.
So,
you know,
basically what I'm kinda getting and I hear is like,
the,
the National Academy of Sciences and Engineering,
you know,
they,
disagree with how you interpret it,
their findings and then these people,
how you interpreted their fines.
Okay.
But Ziva is only one of the 16 members.
I get that.
But if we asked other members,
I think that they would all say the same thing because Alex,
wouldn't you be upset if someone just quoted one part of your book and then left
out all the other parts?
I mean,
I would think that would be a huge disservice to my work.
I would not want,
I would not have put what they put in a ton of effort into something.
And then for someone to only have,
you know,
the judge just to pick up the part that,
I pet facilities ignores nuanced,
honestly,
if I'd written
the Nis,
yeah,
I'm reporting the NAM report and came out in 2017 and nobody had paid any
attention to it,
which nobody did and nobody did for two years and suddenly people were paying
attention to it.
I'd be pretty happy about that.
But what a,
what Dr. Hart is talking about is in the first chapter of the book,
which I guess you haven't read and I really should have a copy for it.
Stupid of me.
Um,
I've got a copy of my bag
so it's marked off.
But,
so this is fascinating to me.
The,
the British,
you know,
they colonized India and they set up what they called lunatic asylum was really
psychiatric hospitals,
sort of very primitive psychiatric hospitals.
And they were really initially for soldiers in the Indian army and they were run
by British doctors.
And what these doctors really as early as like the lead 1850s and sixties
noticed was that a lot of the people who showed up in these hospitals were
showing up with candidate.
What they called Ganja actually in India is called Ganja or Bong,
which is a very weak preparation of a,
of,
of basically uh,
uh,
Indian hemp,
just sort of low grade cannabis.
Um,
and so,
and so they started counting and they realized the 20 to 30% of the people who
were coming to asylums were heavy cannabis users.
And that was way more than alcohol.
It's more than opium.
And it's really fascinating.
Doctor named George Francis.
William Ewans wrote a book in 1908 and he looked at the evidence and,
and it is amazing to hear how he described schizophrenia,
how he describes cannabis,
how he describes the cases of violence around cannabis.
It's like,
it's like any psychiatrist today.
Certainly any forensic psychiatrists like my wife would,
would like,
everything in the book would ring completely true.
And it was so fascinating to me to stumble on this and realize this is something
people have been talking about for more than a hundred years.
Hmm.
So could we,
uh,
agreed that there are some people where cannabis is not a good idea.
Absolutely.
Right.
We can agree that I think we all agree.
Um,
we're also
agree that some people can't eat peanuts.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Right.
And it's not the same thing though,
but yet,
you know why peanuts kill you?
That's w yeah,
it's more dangerous.
So these 600 a year people die from peanuts.
So I think more people die from cannabis as a result of that homicide and the
suicide.
Okay.
Well,
there's no correlation.
There's no paper that they know somebody has got to do the work.
Blame a minute.
But why are you saying that then?
Because I've looked at enough data to tell me,
you think marijuana is causing homicides.
Oh yeah.
This is what the book is about,
but it didn't.
How so?
And what was,
it causes paranoia and psychosis in people.
And paranoid psychosis are huge risks for homicide and schizophrenia.
Studies that refute that was starting.
No studies that refute that.
Paranoia and psychosis are huge risks for homicide.
Schizophrenia is a 20 x 20 times Joe.
Well,
Jamie,
I sent you a document,
uh,
yesterday.
I mean there's,
there's multiple studies that show that,
you know,
marijuana laws are not associated with any type of violence.
This was just talking about the drug.
So the use of the drug,
which could possibly trigger psychosis,
psychosis and schizophrenia,
which are correlated with murder.
So what you're saying,
they're not correlated their triggers.
That's an absolute fact.
Triggers because of the paranoia and delusions and you think that someone's out
to get you and they're not absolutely.
I mean the,
the out of the numbers.
Okay.
So the numbers are,
if you are,
if you have a diagnosis of schizophrenia,
uh,
you are 20 times as likely to commit.
Homicide is somebody who's healthy.
Now.
It's actually worse than that for cannabis.
Okay.
And here's why.
What,
so the National Alliance for mental illness and the mental illness,
advocacy,
advocacy groups hate talking about this.
Why do they hate talking about it?
Obviously,
because it stigmatizes people with mental illness.
So what they say,
and this is true,
is if you have a diagnosis,
but you're taking your anti psychotics,
even though the side effects might be unpleasant,
you're in treatment,
you're,
you're not using recreational drugs.
Your risk for violence isn't that high.
It's not that much higher than a healthy person.
Okay.
And you know,
fortunately healthy people don't commit murder that often.
The problem is if you've,
if you think about the math for half a second,
if there's this one group of people who don't have a very high risk for murder
or serious violence,
who,
because they're not using,
because they are on antipsychotics,
it means that the excess risk in the people who are using and who's untrue
psychosis is untreated.
It must be spectacularly high.
And the numbers bear that out.
So,
so there's a really good study from last year,
2018 it's small group of patients in,
um,
in Switzerland.
Switzerland is a safe country as a low base crime rate,
but 50% of the people who were using cannabis and had psychosis over a three
year period committed violence in that group of people.
That's mostly twentysomething men.
Well,
you know,
there's,
there's a study here and I just sent it to uh,
Jamie and it's,
it's titled,
um,
risk factors for
violence in psychosis,
a systemic review and Meta analysis of 110 studies.
So,
you know,
that's quite a few studies.
Okay.
So,
um,
you know,
let me just,
just read a part of it out too.
So if violence was strongly associated with a history of polysubstance abuse,
strongly associated with diagnosis,
cooperated substance use disorder and recent substance misuse and moderately
associated with it,
history of alcohol misuse,
a history of substance misuse,
uh,
recent alcohol misuse,
recent drug misuse,
and a history of drug abuse.
It was on clear if there was an association between violence and history of
cannabis misuse.
So again,
this is 110 studies.
Uh,
they very carefully looked at all of the different risk factors as to what could
trigger violence.
Just let me finish aocs and what they said,
again,
it was unclear if there was an association between violence and a history of
cannabis misuse.
Right?
So that's 110 studies.
So cannabis use in there is going to get locked in with polysubstance use
because a lot of people will use,
are going to be using other drugs.
Poly substance means multiple substances,
alcohol,
cannabis,
exactly.
So on.
Everything else was found to have significant statistical significance.
And I have not,
not just mine that a doctor heard assignment.
I'd like to look at it without looking at it.
I can't push back as hard as I would like.
What I can tell you is that I have many studies in the book that show that
cannabis use is associated with violence in people with psychosis.
Okay.
And more broadly,
it's associated with violence in the general population in large studies,
in studies of high school students and bullying in studies of people who were
vacationing in a visa in,
in,
in studies of young men in China and the UK.
There are big studies out there that show cannabis use is associated with
violence.
Uh,
Beazer Ibiza
and I got grilled over there for that.
They get manager,
I suppose to kill people just said it.
Yeah.
So some dignitary or royal person had a list,
right?
Isn't that how it all starts at true?
Yeah.
I believe so.
Noted.
Yeah.
The way the people in Spain pronounce words was directly affected by this one
person apparently.
But,
um,
so this,
uh,
these,
this correlation,
um,
between people that have schizophrenia and using cannabis,
how do you,
is is schizophrenia a diagnosis?
It's purely based on behavior basically.
Yes.
Yeah.
It's a clinic.
There is no blood tests and do a brain scan.
It's basically how you behave and what you tell the doctor about how you're
feeling.
Charise or it's very subjective,
how so big because you're,
you're asking
skin someone basically a series of questions.
I mean,
it's no different than,
you know,
depression really.
I mean,
you just,
just asking someone a series of questions and then based upon that,
uh,
which is very subjective,
then you're going to make,
you know,
a clinical decision.
Whereas when it's like a blood test,
like if someone you know,
passes,
uh,
you know,
a certain amount of,
of hemoglobin a one C,
you know,
depending on which chart you're looking at,
then you're going to call that person prediabetic or diabetic.
But,
you know,
unfortunately we just don't have those objective measurements.
And again,
that's why,
you know,
Alex was saying earlier that,
um,
that,
you know,
the,
uh,
they couldn't really figure out,
you know,
how many people in the United States had had schizophrenia.
And I understand that,
but at the same time too,
I mean,
it's okay to,
to adjust,
you know,
the way that you diagnose someone over the course of the years and you learn
things because,
you know,
you could easily say that almost everyone has some type of mental illness.
And I mean,
people should understand that,
you know,
there's seven different basic human emotions.
You know,
I've talked to is for,
it's,
there's,
there's anger,
there's contempt,
uh,
there's,
there's discuss,
there's fear,
sadness,
surprise and happiness.
That's seven.
So,
you know,
depending on which way surprise goes.
I mean,
six out of those seven are negative,
right?
Because we're wired to basically detect threats.
So,
you know,
um,
we're,
we're making,
you know,
the,
all these diagnosis,
I think we have to be careful because you have,
some people are calling themselves depressed and some people are calling
themselves anxious when really,
you know,
they're just not dealing with basic human emotions that they need to understand
and need to deal with.
Like people are getting angry about being angry or like depressed about being
depressed.
Like if you feel one of these emotions just kind of sit with it and just kind of
reflect on it.
And I think you know,
that that's a much,
much better way to kind of kind of tea to tease things out.
But you want to come back to my original point.
I think that,
you know,
more people are understanding that um,
we don't just need to give out a pill for everything and that everyone shouldn't
just be labeled as having a mental health diagnosis because if things just keep
going the way they are,
you know what's,
by 2040 it's going to be like 50% of people are going to have like a mental
health disorder.
So like people just need to understand that life is hard.
You got to deal with these emotions.
Sometimes it's not that big of a deal.
And that's why for some fun and that's what some folks,
for some folks,
and that's why I'm such a big thing of,
of Jordan Peterson because you know he's,
he's,
he's kind of tough on people.
Don't let me stop.
Sure.
Cause Jordan Peterson was on Ssri is for years we got,
it was a long,
long time like for a long,
long time as was his family.
And what's crazy about him is what got him off is a carnivore diet elimination
diet where he only eats meat with salt and drinks water and the healthier than
he's ever been in his life.
And that is another massively controversial subject.
Let me push back a little bit cause I think people,
you know,
as controversial as the book has been about,
uh,
about cannabis in psychosis,
this issue is even
more controversial.
And obviously for,
for for a fair number of people,
it doesn't really,
it doesn't sync with the stereotype.
It doesn't say,
it doesn't say with how they've experienced cannabis use.
Right.
So I think,
I think alcohol's a really interesting comparison.
Sorry.
Um,
I'm the Canadian.
well you have to go national.
We were talking about,
my wife's actually from new family,
new familiar as in understand marijuana.
A Newfoundland trained myself to say that what you're telling me I'm wrong.
Liquid Jamie just pulled up.
While marijuana use increases violent behavior,
50 year study finds casual link between cannabis and subsequent violent
behavior.
A new research published online in advance of print of the journal.
It's like a psychological medicine concludes.
The continued use of cannabis causes violent behavior as a direct result of
changes in brain function that are caused by smoking weed.
Over many years,
researchers have long debated a possible link between the use of marijuana and
violent crime in contrast to alcohol,
meth,
and many other illegal drugs.
The metabolic effects of cannabis scene unsuited to promoting violent behavior.
However,
ample,
ample previous research has linked marijuana use to increased violent behavior.
The sticky problem in such studies are that many confounding factors,
cofounding factors,
uh,
involved in interpreting this correlation.
So,
so,
okay.
It is very difficult to determine whether or not any statistical correlation
between marijuana use and violent behavior are,
uh,
cash causally linked or instead the two associated,
or instead the two are associated through some other factors such as
socioeconomic status,
personality traits are many other variables that are related to the propensity
to use marijuana.
Um,
so I think it's a fairly good summary of,
of,
of the issues.
What's up.
James Study
came from a 411 boys who were born in 1953 in London,
97% of which were Caucasian.
And all of them are raised in two parent households.
So,
so you know,
so those people are relatively stable if they're two family,
two parent households to hand parents beat to shit.
And Dad's also,
no,
it's possible.
But so,
so let me so,
so,
so I think the alcohol comparison is again a good one because anybody who's ever
been in a bar at 9:00 PM and gone back at 2:00 AM knows that alcohol does
inhibits people.
Right.
It causes fights,
right.
It makes people loud.
It makes a lot of fucking does.
Does
it's good and bad.
I don't know if that's good.
I mean,
sometimes it makes people,
it's alcohol and sex are a terrible idea.
It certainly causes some sexual violence.
Sure.
Okay.
But at the same time,
everybody knows that you can have a drink.
You know,
you can have a beer at the backyard barbecue,
you can enter.
It doesn't mean
that you're going to get in a fight and you actually might enhance your
conversation,
social lubricants,
all that good stuff,
good stuff.
And you might even know people.
I mean,
I do know people who I would say have a problem with drinking.
Okay.
But it's mostly they're sitting at home drinking scotch,
watching baseball until they fall asleep that night.
Now that's obviously not a healthy way to use alcohol,
but it doesn't make them violent.
But we know on a population basis that alcohol causes violence.
It causes drunk driving,
it causes problems.
And it said that in this study that I quoted earlier,
but it's,
it's a,
that alcohol,
again,
they didn't their soy cannabis,
they weren't sure.
Right?
So,
okay.
But so this is again,
I would like to read the paper that you're quoting from because I have so much
other research,
but here's,
here's what I'm saying about cannabis.
Okay.
Cannabis for a lot of people.
Yeah.
They can just smoke it.
And as people,
you know,
as many people have tweeted at me,
the only thing I attacked was a bowl of Nachos.
Right.
And so and so that's true for some people,
but that could be sent with the alcohol as well.
That's exactly logical variable.
And there's so many studies that say that,
that the cannabis laws have actually decreased crime.
Looking at studying.
She gotta.
Let me finish.
Let him finish.
Go ahead.
So,
so
even though for many people,
cannabis isn't going to cause violence,
that doesn't mean it can't cause violence in some people especially,
or at least could be affected at least could be a factor,
especially with the kind of violence that I am talking about.
And then I write about in the book,
which is again,
so alcohol,
it may be,
makes argument into a brawl.
It makes a brawl into something where somebody picks up a stick.
It makes that into something where somebody pulls out a knife,
it escalates.
Cannabis is different.
Cannabis Causes Paranoia and psychosis.
And it certainly causes us things temporarily,
even if it doesn't cause them permanently.
So a distortion in reality that could lead to you doing something terrible.
And it's usually to somebody you're not actually fighting with.
It's a family member.
The worst cases that I've,
and I've really seen a lot of these cases are basically innocent family members
who are just in the way.
When somebody loses touch with reality and literally thinks like this,
my 85 year old grandmother is going to kill me,
so I better stab her to death first.
That happens.
It happens a lot.
And if you look at the amount of violence that people with psychosis command on
a population level basis,
it looks like people with schizophrenia commit about six to 10% of all the
murders in this country and it looks like people would sort of broader diff,
more broadly defined psychosis.
Again,
bipolar with psychosis,
other psychotic conditions,
temporary psychosis,
they might be responsible for as much as 20% of the violent crime in the United
States.
That's a lot of violent crime.
And what I am saying is that it is quite clear that drug use mediates that
violent crime.
In other words,
if you're not using,
you can keep your impulses in check,
but when you do use,
you become dangerous.
So when
we're talking about biological variability,
if we factor in schizophrenia,
essentially what you're saying is that there are people that have schizophrenia
that don't commit violence,
but that they're much more likely to commit violence if you add some sort of
psych medication,
whether it's marijuana,
whether it's something else,
it perturbs reality for them.
And particularly marijuana because hotbox bring down the
recreational drugs,
the worst cases of all our cannabis and a stimulant.
Because to the they both like cocaine or meth.
Exactly.
Yeah.
So when you get that,
you get paranoid from two sources and you get the only good thing about cannabis
from this point of view as it kind of knocks people down a little bit,
but meth brings them right back.
So is it fair to say that what we don't know is that we don't know whether or
not these people like this young band with his terrible story from Connecticut?
Yes.
We don't know whether or not he would have become a schizophrenia and exhibited
those symptoms without the marijuana.
We really don't know.
But we do know he did with it.
That's,
that's correct.
And what I would also say is that for somebody like that,
and this is quite clear on a population level basis with people with
schizophrenia is you've got to discourage them from using,
really have to be disclosed because it brings out the worst.
Right.
And,
and you know somebody said this,
a a friend of mine,
old friend of mine from the New York Times said,
so every time there's a hurricane people,
some people on the right say,
well you can't prove that global warming cause that one hurricane that would've
happened anyway and he and there,
right,
you can't prove it and you can't prove that any one case of psychosis was caused
by marijuana.
But when you look at the big studies at the population level data,
the association is really clear and everything points the same way and the
synthetic cannabinoids k two and spice,
those can clearly produce psychosis in people and people with psychosis tend to
slip back into it if they use at some point you got to start to say to yourself,
why does everything go the same way?
I also have a personal friend and I'd really didn't think about this guy,
but there's another personal friend that I know that it is a martial arts
instructor that had a psychotic break.
He became schizophrenia and he's a regular marijuana user.
And the people around him associated that with that.
And in fact people that are regular cannabis users,
we're trying to get them to stop using marijuana or close to being on the edge.
Any use a little bit of of cannabis for sure it be Tyson.
And this guy was not on the edge when I knew him,
when I knew him,
he was very rational,
very rational.
But something happened somewhere along the line was he,
did he become a pretty heavy smoker over time?
I do not know because we don't live in the same area anymore,
but he got really heavily,
uh,
really heavily medicated and did some really crazy shit and want to be in
hospitalized.
And this was not the case before.
I mean,
whatever it was that triggered him.
when I was around him when he was younger,
I would have said he's a total normal guy.
And I would have never saw that coming.
He was a heavy marijuana user,
heavy,
heavy.
But I don't,
I don't know how he's doing now.
I hope he's okay.
But we're,
you know,
we have mutual friends.
Yeah.
And uh,
he became,
uh,
schizophrenia and,
and you know,
you will see,
you know,
cases like that.
But you know,
when you do look at a lot of the larger data on,
on cannabis and violence,
I mean it's just,
it's just not there.
Like there's lots of data that suggests that,
you know,
medical marijuana laws for example,
can actually have a decrease in overall.
I mean,
I think there's a study that says that no comfort to the people who lose their
children because of the psychotropics.
That's right.
And those studies are really bad.
So the place that you can criticize the bad though,
because there,
because state level data is not great.
The place the book has been criticized for Andra,
there was a rand review though in 2013.
And I mean that,
that's again that stated that include marijuana use does not induce violent
crime and the links between marijuana use and property crime are thin there.
I think we all agree that marijuana use by itself with people that aren't
schizophrenia probably does it induce violent crime.
But with people that are schizophrenia or people where it triggers
schizophrenia,
it could potentially induced violent crime.
My friend did not get violent,
although he did do a violent thing.
It wasn't to a person.
Um,
I think,
I think we have to be really careful because there's no,
just like with diet,
just like with food and you know,
like a allergies,
all these different variabilities when it comes to human beings.
I think we have to be really,
really careful about lumping all people together when it comes to how they get
affected by various compounds.
So the state level,
if you want,
I'll,
the police,
the book has been criticized in my mind,
sort of the most fairly is it points out that in the four states that legalized
first,
which is Alaska,
Washington,
Oregon,
Colorado.
Um,
if you look at 2013 and then you compare that to 2017 murders and agg assault,
violent crime,
um,
are up substantially in those states and substantially more than in the u s can
I stop you there?
But is there a possibility there's a correlation between organized crime?
He goes,
one of the things about selling marijuana is the people that have always been
selling marijuana have been criminals.
When you make things legal and estate,
the people that were selling it illegal flock to that state.
And that's been proven to be true,
that there's,
there's a direct correlation between people being robbed,
that there was also a significant problem with credit cards and banks where
everyone was having to do all their transactions with cash.
There was a lot of violences was associated with marijuana in regards to that
and also massive increase in population.
And so the reason why Trump has actually not really against cannabis in some
ways it's because he feels that if we have medical marijuana laws that
especially the states that are,
that,
that are border states,
that the crime's gonna drop drops a lot tremendously.
And it has dropped.
They did a study last year and it dropped over 50% is all around 7% in Arizona.
And then again,
you know Benjamin Hanson
who,
who's,
who's an economist,
the wrong data.
So first let's talk over each other.
Okay,
so he,
he said that the murder rate did not demonstrate that marijuana legalization and
increases violence and then it may have actually demonstrated that legalization
is slightly decreased fonts and he thinks that that the reason that there was an
increase in the murder rate,
particularly in Washington is because there was a large income gap.
They say that Washington has the 10th largest income gap in the United States.
That's why.
How did that change how that corresponds to the murderer?
Good question though.
I'm so,
I haven't,
you know,
I didn't get to speak with Benjamin to about this,
but sounds like confirmation bias.
Well he,
I mean that is one thing that has been shown to increase mental illness like
we've talked about and can definitely increase violence is when you have an
income gap.
And how's the income gap shifted that directly correlates to the legalization of
marijuana because during the scene,
because during the same period,
the income gap,
particularly in Washington increased.
So he feels that,
you know,
it's corresponding number,
right.
So he feels that it's likely more,
more to that.
And I mean he,
I mean,
I understand,
but I mean you have to respect this guy,
man.
I don't respect him because I know what he did with his data.
And tell me
this,
this is maddening to me.
Violent crime in those four states increased more rapidly than in the u s period
between 2013 and 2017 Jamie just posted this,
conjecture aside,
no credible data exists.
It supports a significant association between the increase in violent crime and
marijuana legalization.
Furthermore,
studies suggest that so far violent crime decreases in states with legalized
medical marijuana until new research credibly suggest otherwise.
The claim that a demonstratable link between the two exists will remain
classified as false.
So that's just not true.
Okay?
I know it's Snopes.
Okay.
And I know we trust Snopes.
I don't trust them that
I was gonna say that too.
But they're,
they give all of their,
their source.
So again,
do you,
are you,
where are these sources?
I've read this stuff and what's wrong with them here?
Let me just go back to what I'm saying.
Please do it.
2013 Oregon,
Washington,
Colorado,
Alaska.
There are 450 murders in those four states.
There are 30,000 agg assault period.
Okay.
2017 Oregon,
Washington,
Colorado,
Alaska.
There are 620 murders in those four states.
That's an almost 40% increase.
There are 38,000 agg assaults.
That's a 25% increase.
If you adjust for population,
you still get big increases in Denver,
2018 almost 70 murders.
There were about 35 and 2013.
Seattle 27 2018 there were 34 35 murders.
There were,
I think 19 in 2013 these increases are real.
Okay,
now,
okay.
Can we say
that marijuana legalization caused those increases?
We cannot yet.
There are other possibilities.
And you're,
what are those?
Um,
well,
one positive first of all,
population did increase.
It's also possible that these states,
quote unquote imported violent crime.
And other ones that you've got a population of transients coming in in part
because marijuana was legal and those people are likely to commit violent crime
and on top of that organized crime people that are selling.
Absolutely.
There may have been some people who are exporting to to Nebraska,
to Minnesota,
to other states.
There's crime associated with that,
but what I am saying is that unequivocally,
unequivocally,
the people who said legalization is going to decrease violent crime and people
did say that.
And Cory booker in 2010 17 said it,
he said that it actually had decreased violent crime in states that legalized
and he didn't say it randomly.
He said it when he was introducing legislation to legalize marijuana on the
federal level.
Those people are wrong and they need to stop saying it.
I know.
And by the way that Oregon economists used,
he used the wrong data set for his charts.
Okay.
He used,
I used the real numbers.
Okay.
The FBI homicide numbers.
He used numbers that include justifiable homicides,
police,
the FBI report that the murder rate went up 1% from 2015 to 2016 as compared to
the nationwide,
which one?
It was 3.9% and then it dropped by 11.6% between 2016 and 20 seconds.
I do not know what you're talking about.
Those are FBI numbers of breeding,
not know what you're talking about.
The numbers are clear.
Okay.
I use them reading them right now.
2016 release of FBI uniform crime reports from Oregon.
Okay.
Yes,
Oregon.
You're not reading the reports from the United States.
You're picking one state for women showing something will state that has
legalized medical cannabis over the entire country from that time period too.
So to pick those four states where marijuana was legalized,
sort of cherry picking,
picking every state where there were legalized and comparing it to the whole
country,
the whole country,
the whole country.
You'll see a similar,
is it a similar increase?
That's what I'm trying to
pull back so we can see the whole stuff.
So,
first of all,
that's a violent crime coordinators and ag out crime,
violent crime and that ag assaults,
aren't they?
No.
So so,
so the four categories of violent crime or murder,
agg assault,
robbery and rape.
Rape has sort of gone sideways the last few years.
Robberies actually have gone down.
It's murders and ag assaults that are interpersonal violent crime.
Okay.
Just to go back to this Oregon economist,
because this maddens me,
he used a Dataset that is not the standard data set to report murder rate.
What is the difference?
He used the data set that includes justifiable homicides,
meaning I'm in my house,
you come in,
I shoot you and kill you.
The police don't charge me with anything and police homicides,
but you use your book published.
Let's not let it interrupt.
Let me finish.
Those two categories of crime are not likely to be impacted by cannabis use.
Cops are not smoking when they're on patrol eyes.
Hope.
And if you are using,
you're very unlikely to have your murder viewed as justifiable homicide.
The fair comparison is the base murder rate in the u s and that's the number
that I used.
And I am telling you,
I mean I know these numbers,
I sleep,
I wake up with these numbers,
cannabis,
the for cannabis legal states on a per capita basis,
crime murders rose 31% on a per capita basis in those four states over the 2013,
2017 period.
Maybe,
I'm sorry I said 31.
Maybe it's 29%.
So maybe I say I woke up anyway.
The the,
for the US it's 18% 29% versus 18%.
That's the gap.
And I am not saying that I know that cannabis legalization cause that gap,
what I'm saying is people need to stop claiming that cannabis legalization
reduces violent crime.
It in,
it has increased in those tasks.
You in those states was at universal,
the increase,
was it almost identical?
Yes.
Alaska was the most,
uh,
then I think murders went up more in college in Washington.
Uh,
and what's also interesting,
Joe,
if you're,
if you really want to go into the numbers,
is the gap actually widens year by year.
So that's sort of what you would expect if this is the result of a psychometric
effect.
In other words,
a psychosis causing effect because cannabis doesn't cause psychosis right away.
People break down.
But if it's causing heavy use and some of those people are sliding into paranoia
and psychosis,
you'd sort of expect the gap to increase over time.
And that's what's happened.
Okay.
So,
you know,
I'm gonna go back again to the Netherlands.
Okay.
Because they've had,
you know,
cannabis legalized forever and they have one fifth of the homicide rate that the
United States does.
And they also have a lower cannabis use.
That's true.
They also very,
but still,
you know,
one warrior kick boxers,
but,
uh,
one,
one fifth.
I mean,
it's still,
it's,
it's pretty drastic overall.
And again,
you know,
Alex,
I appreciate some of the reason we're talking about the correlation between
cannabis use.
One of the things that,
yeah,
we
have to accept it in America is that when you're in a place like the Netherlands
has a long and accepted history of use,
people are accustomed to it.
So I think things kind of even out.
I think one of the things that we're dealing with with the United States is
people that have just,
they don't,
they don't have a long history of experience and it becomes legal and then they
use it.
And maybe some of them like we're talking about don't have a tolerance for it,
have too much.
And I was talking about with my friend who's like this really cotton,
the one who,
uh,
had an edible and became suicidal and was fucked up for weeks.
You guys very confident,
very articulate,
very intelligent.
He's not a,
not a Weirdo,
not
a non transient extreme,
extremely successful.
You know,
I think there are,
there are variables that we need to take into consideration and there's certain
human beings that exhibit a pattern of behavior that's directly correlated to
cannabis use that I don't experience.
So if I,
I could say from my own personal biases that that's bullshit.
That's nothing.
It doesn't do anything.
I've been smoking for years,
doesn't do shit.
Well you probably don't have one of those three genes that we were talking about
and you probably also to,
um,
you know,
don't overuse or you have some type of,
um,
legitimacy as to why you are,
you are using it.
And you know what,
I want to keep going with this.
But you know,
at the end of the show,
I think that we should make some type of like recommendations for people just
because I hate when,
you know,
you have this big three hour podcasts and then at the end of it it's just like,
hey guys,
just be safe.
It's like,
it's like,
let's have
fun.
Let's have
type of like,
um,
recommendations.
Like I love the podcast with,
uh,
with,
with Chris Kresser and Joel.
Right?
But,
um,
at the,
at the end of it was just sort of like,
hey guys,
do anything there can die.
Most people realize that one person was going on data and the other person was
for sure.
I find it so fascinating that now when you think back through your,
through your life,
you've,
you've thought of somebody who was affected,
that there were several people.
I'll bet I'll bet as you think about it,
you'll think of more people maybe.
But those are the big ones.
And like I said,
my friend who is a martial arts instructor was a pretty significant issue with a
lot of our friends.
We were trying to figure out what was wrong with him beforehand.
He was sending me these videos that didn't make any sense.
And uh,
I was like,
what in the fuck is this?
Like I'll,
I'll explain to you more often Arabic so I don't have to uh,
out this guy.
But what will the,
all a lot of people that were close to him were really seriously concerned.
Now is it something that would have happened anyway?
I don't know.
He's in his twenties.
How old is that?
Late twenties 20.
You know,
that's right around the age.
So it is,
it's a little,
a little bit late Ish.
Like,
cause like I said,
a lot of the studies,
even when you look at the ones on adolescents,
like for sure it's below,
like they've,
they have done studies like blow 18 is worse than say below 25 blow 15 is worse
than say 18.
Like the younger you go the worst and he seems to be fine now.
That's good.
Yeah.
Using now,
I don't know.
And it's,
uh,
you know,
I'm not an expert on the subject,
but it's,
it's because of this,
um,
if somebody called pruning that we go through,
so everyone goes through this and basically if your adolescents,
you're going to drop off some,
some weak neuroconnections to kind of pick up some stronger ones.
So,
you know,
it's the best way to kind of explain it.
Um,
when you use cannabis,
you can potentially accelerate
that process.
And then because you accelerate that process,
you don't get those good neuro connections.
And then,
you know,
people unfortunately,
develop things like,
like psychosis and,
um,
and,
and schizophrenia.
So,
you know,
that's kind of where they were,
where the issue lies.
So,
you know,
one thing that I am very happy,
uh,
that we're talking about and I know Alex will be too,
is that,
you know,
we want to discuss the benefits and in this podcast,
make sure that people understand that,
you know,
I believe that marijuana is Madison.
It's an excellent medicine.
Um,
but the other thing though too is we do want to mitigate the risks because there
are real risks out there.
So,
you know,
I do appreciate,
um,
US talking about adolescence and making sure that they do stay away from Canton.
This especially,
that's why I read these,
you know,
these cases is a case file sometimes.
Then,
you know,
the kids started using when he was 11 and you know,
it's like that kid never had a chance.
Right.
I mean,
and obviously the,
oftentimes these are kids coming from disadvantaged backgrounds anyway,
but you know,
they're using by 11 and it's 16.
They put,
you know,
put a gun to somebody's head and pull the trigger.
I mean
the pre adolescent and early teen news,
we got to do everything we can to stop.
The problem is,
yeah,
like if you,
if you smoke pot in junior high,
like say seven,
eight,
nine,
like you're probably going to smoke pot in high school.
Like that's the,
I mean,
that's what I saw when we went out when I was growing up and you know,
even when I was a home for Christmas for,
for a few days,
like yeah,
a couple of my friends even talked about,
you know,
um,
some people that we knew,
you know,
smoked pot in high school and like now like they're there,
they're crazy or they're not really doing too too much,
you know,
so you do have to be careful with that.
I think we're dealing with a lot of ignorance.
We're dealing with a lot of ignorance and occur when it comes to biological
variability,
right?
We,
we,
we don't really understand how a lot of these different things affect people,
including like just diet and what,
what,
what causes depression.
Like,
how much,
how much of what we constitute or what we decide is depression.
Is Inflammation a poor gut health?
There's a lot of variables.
There's a lot of them.
Marijuana is absolutely one of those variables.
And uh,
again,
I don't have an issue with it.
I liked it.
I love this stuff,
but it does,
it doesn't fuck with me,
but I'm also honest and so I see these people where it's pretty obvious to me
that something's going on and that marijuana is not a good idea for them.
And I just think,
you know,
like I said in the past,
I myself have been guilty of using this,
uh,
this sort of a blanket description of it as being a positive influence and that
it's a good thing for people.
I don't think it's a good thing for everybody.
No,
it's definitely not a good thing for everybody and it's definitely not a good
thing for the people who have those genetics that I,
that I discussed earlier.
And you know,
also too,
like,
you know,
if you,
you need to have some type of like self awareness,
like the people who you know don't do well with cannabis,
you know,
you shouldn't have
to have your friends tell you that he came in like you're not doing too well.
You should be able to figure out yourself.
But that's hard for people.
I mean that's one of the most difficult things for people to do as itself.
Upset,
self assess to be objective,
you know?
And,
and that it's,
I've obviously I've heard from a lot of people who used heavily and seen other
people who've used heavily in the last month and I think is very interesting why
people continue to use when they're getting paranoid and,
and you know,
the most cogent argument,
and again,
I'm,
I'm not,
you know,
I've smoked a handful of times in college and African,
I actually don't think I'd be comfortable using high THC cannabis now knowing
what I know.
But anyway,
so the p the,
the people,
the most Godson,
Ryan here,
okay,
I'm going to get hot box.
I'll give you this shit to put [inaudible] on the
with the most,
the most cogent argument.
W I thought it was so interesting.
This guy said,
well you know my friends,
I would talk to them and say,
I'm paranoid now but I'm going to smoke through it.
I'm going to smoke so much that I'm almost comfortable being paranoid and I
think that's a dangerous thing to do to your mind cause you're,
you're sort of counting on being able to step back from that and stop using you.
That's a,
that's a silly way of looking at it.
I think that some of what we call paranoia,
just normal paranoia is hypersensitivity and hyper awareness and awareness to a
lot of things that you're putting off in the back of your head because in order
to function as a normal person and get through this life,
you can't really be aware of everything.
Otherwise you'd be paralyzed by fear.
We're in space.
Okay,
we are on a gigantic ball.
It's spinning a thousand miles an hour hurling through infinity.
This,
this is reality,
this and take us out thin layer of gas.
It's protecting us from everything that's flying around in our solar system.
By the way.
At best you get me five years and then it's all right and even if you make it to
a hundred the last 15
[inaudible] stem cells and stuff.
Yeah,
maybe a little live to be 300 what do you do with the universe is infinite like
you're going to die.
Like the sun is going to end like at the end.
I mean imagine if people do live to an infinite number where we realized that
fucking son is dying.
You're going to freak out about that.
I mean it's all relative,
right?
So there,
there's only so much you really can think about it and some of what paranoia is
is this hyper awareness of all these variables that you really haven't,
haven't considered.
And then also we were talking about before,
the things that can be beneficial to the hyper awareness of how you communicated
with people.
Maybe you could have done a better job with that.
Maybe you,
you came in hot,
maybe you were upset about something else when you ran into them.
You already had a seven and they brought you to a 10 it was totally unnecessary.
Within a normal situation you would have only been at a too that those things
are real and sometimes marijuana helps highlight all the errors in your way.
I think it can be a tool but my description of it is like any other tool
like a hammer,
you can build a house with a hammer or you can just hit yourself in the Dick if
you're fucking crazy and this,
this is something that I think we should consider when we're discussing almost
any psychedelic medicine and I think that,
I really do believe that marijuana is a psychedelic and I don't even think it's
a mild one,
especially when it's an edible form.
I don't think it's mild at all.
Yeah,
I mean the,
there's some people that that come in to my office for example and like just
when I meet them,
like after one or two minutes I was just,
I just got it the side of my head,
this person's not using THC like this.
This person is anxious with gives you that.
It,
was that what it is?
Anxious.
Yeah.
It's just a feeling of,
um,
they're not really,
they're not someone who can just sit and kind of like be by themself,
you know,
they just kind of give me the impression that,
um,
you know,
they're,
they're not going to do well with,
with cannabis because if they have any type of change in their,
um,
in their psyche,
they're going to see that as bad.
That's bad.
You know,
and like you got it when you're using cannabis,
you,
you have to be sewn and who,
who knows that okay.
Are going to get a little bit of maybe paranoia and out or at least my psyche is
going to change a little bit.
I am using,
you know,
psychoactive substance and not be able to freak out.
Right.
But some people,
um,
you know,
I know that if they used a little bit of Thc,
they probably would have a freak out.
They probably would have a bad experience.
Generally it's people who are,
you know,
very,
very fearful.
Now,
the other side of that coin though is that if you CBD and like we discussed
earlier,
that could decrease learned fear,
right?
So,
so that,
so that's something that's,
that's really helpful for those patients.
But you know,
I do agree that,
um,
you know,
we have to be careful about using high THC and certain groups of people.
For sure.
You
know,
I think one of the,
and it's great to hear a doctor heart say this,
I,
one of the real disappointments for me with this book has been really the
biggest disappointing for me has been that the DPA,
the drug policy alliance,
and that some of the other advocates,
they just want to yell at me.
And I want to say that I don't understand correlation and causation and that I'm
cherry picking studies.
Let's,
let's acknowledge that a lot of people use this drug and that's true,
whether it's legal or not.
And let's acknowledge that.
Probably in 2020 certainly if there's a democrat elected,
most of the Democratic candidates have said they,
they favor legalization.
There will legalize cannabis will probably be the law in the United States.
Okay.
And let's talk about what we're going to tell people who are using and,
and,
and you know,
I had this round table with,
uh,
the executive director of the DPA and some other people.
This was a,
this is about a month ago,
you know,
short of shortly after the book came out.
And I propose what I thought were really common sense warnings and she basically
wouldn't agree.
I mean she agreed to like one of the five of them or what were the warnings you
proposed?
It was stuff like,
you know,
if cannabis,
if you have a family history of severe mental illness,
you probably should not use cannabis.
Um,
you probably,
you should not use camp or try to your use
until you're in your 20s,
I think was one of them.
And one of them I thought,
I couldn't believe I was getting pushed back on this was,
was something like,
uh,
if,
if you're having strange,
uh,
thoughts,
especially paranoid thoughts,
will using cannabis,
um,
the drug may be increasing your risk for severe mental illness and you should
not use it.
I mean,
I think that's,
I think if you know,
now look,
we can argue about how severe severe is,
right?
But certainly if you wind up in the er,
even once,
that's a bad sign and I just,
I just don't understand why the legalization can be,
look,
I can understand why people who are selling this drug don't care.
Right?
We know if you know,
if tobacco is taught us,
one thing is that when you're selling a product,
you will sell it to people even if it kills them.
Okay.
But I don't understand why these people who are supposed to be science driven
and supposed to be thinking about the greater good won't agree to reasonable
discussions about the what the warnings should be on this.
I think you did yourself a slight disservice by not including some of the
beneficial aspects of cannabis.
I understand your perspective.
I understand why you were doing that because you really wanted to highlight the
dangerous,
but I think that's one of the things that they can point to when they say you
cherry picked data.
But I think that also it's really important to when you're having these kinds of
conversations to have a long one.
I mean this,
we've really covered the full gamut.
Yes.
Right.
And I think that's probably one of the reasons why bill Maher didn't want to
have you on because he's got five other people on the panel.
Everybody's talking over everybody and you have five minutes to get your case
out.
And I don't think it's possible.
I think this is a really,
this is a long complicated discussion that has to do with biological variability
is it has to do with unique situations with human,
uh,
the human psychology,
the way the brain functions,
whether or not it can act as a trigger to schizophrenia where someone may not
have ever experienced that trigger without it.
Maybe if they just became a long distance runner and they would have lived a
healthy life with no psychotic breaks at all,
we don't really know.
And unfortunately,
once someone goes off the deep end,
we might never find out.
And sorry,
go on.
No,
I'm just saying,
I think we have to be very careful in saying we know what it does.
We know what anything does.
Cause you don't know,
you know what it does for you.
You know,
some,
some people can't eat fish,
you know,
they,
they fucking shellfish and their,
their throats seizes up.
We,
there's so many variables when it comes to the human body,
whether it's your genetics or you know,
w what you've eaten in the past and how it's shaped your gut biome.
There's so much that we don't know and don't understand about how we interact
with all the various substances that we take into our body.
Yes.
Yeah.
What one thing though too,
you know,
I noticed in your book,
Alex,
is that,
you know,
you said that you didn't think that cannabis can help the opioid epidemic.
Is that true?
I certainly don't think it's a good idea for people who are at risk of opioid
use.
Okay.
So,
you know,
I have seen a lot of people in my practice,
um,
come off of opioids with cannabis use and there are,
you know,
various medical studies
that do show that people who use cannabis,
Kane came replace opioids,
uh,
with,
with the cannabis space.
Folks feel though that that's a pen in,
you know,
in defense of that does just a patch and they're really the best way to get off
of opiates as a game.
And then I became w w the,
the repeat rate of addiction where people try it again afterwards is really low.
I think,
you know,
one of the things with that is just the accessibility,
the affordability.
Like I've never administered Ibogaine before.
Um,
it's illegal in the United States,
but I mean,
and it's a particularly ruthless medication that I've never tried personally,
but the people that I know that have tried it,
I've had spectacular results,
especially people that have had problems with pills and fracked.
A friend of mine,
my friend Ed Clay,
he opened up a clinic in Mexico based on his own interaction with,
uh,
with pills.
He had an injury.
He got hooked on the pills and a really had a fucking problem.
So went down to Mexico and went through an Ibogaine a session and cured him.
Just whacked it out.
Did it change,
literally changes the way your brain interfaces with your addiction?
It's not,
it's not simply a prospective enhancer.
It looks,
it,
it changes how you,
your body and your brain deal with,
with opiates.
I think a Tim Ferriss is actually talked about that before as well.
Um,
but I mean,
you know,
I've seen it in my practice and there are medical studies,
so I don't think that we should throw out the fact that,
um,
you know,
cannabis can can help the opioid crisis.
And then also too,
you know,
you want to look at it from a clinical perspective,
right?
So we know that opioids can kill people,
Because it acts on the brain.
Stann whereas,
whereas,
you know,
cannabis doesn't,
so,
you know,
you might be saying,
you're just substituting one for the other.
And you know,
sometimes that is true,
but if you're using a less harmful substance,
you know,
to me that's like a huge win,
right?
So if someone you know,
has to drink 12 beers a night versus smoking like one joint,
man,
that's awesome.
I mean,
you look at all,
all these clinics like you look at like Methadone clinics.
I mean,
what are they doing there?
They're trying to get people off one substance to,
you know,
a substance that is a little bit less harmful.
And I think that when you,
when you use cannabis,
you know,
it can be effective,
uh,
for,
for opioids.
It can also be effective for,
for benzodiazepines and for other medicines as well.
So,
you know,
I would it be awesome if everyone would just,
feel happy and great all the time by just exercise and nutrition and you know,
that's what I advocate and that's what I try to do personally.
And that's what I try to,
you know,
say to my patients all the time.
But I understand though that,
you know,
sometimes life is hard.
Sometimes,
you know,
if things hit you,
you have,
you have crisis in your life,
you know,
personal crisis that can throw off your mental health and then you have your get
into a car accident,
you know,
and you could be in really severe pain.
And,
and in those times,
you know,
sometimes diet,
exercise,
meditation,
doing all the right things just isn't quite enough.
And you know,
I think that it's great that we have cannabis for those situations because it
does seem to be,
you know,
very effective and has less side effects compared to some of the other metals is
compared to some of the other medicines that we have traditionally used.
Um,
and you know,
even though,
you know,
I'm talking about opiates and deaths,
we can also talk about insets,
right?
Like nonsteroidal antiinflammatory drugs.
So these drugs can also,
you know,
wreck havoc on your GI system.
Um,
I saw one study,
actually,
I tweeted out,
uh,
Rhonda Patrick tweeted out said that if you use a and sets,
it was really short.
I got to look it up again,
but it was like two weeks.
It can decrease your,
uh,
your gonadotropins,
which can stimulate your testosterone level by like 25%.
And on that note too,
we should talk about,
I can't believe I forgot to talk about this,
but opioids can drastically,
um,
inhibit your,
uh,
your,
testosterone production.
Right?
Which is a huge thing for depression because I've had guys come in to me before,
um,
that have been a really,
really depressed,
you just give them a small amount of testosterone in men.
They're off their antidepressants and they're off to the races.
They're doing great.
So,
you know,
are we creating a lot of people who are,
who are depressed because they're using opiates and their testosterone levels
are low.
And you know,
for men,
I mean having low testosterone,
it's horrible.
You know,
your libido goes,
you know what,
you're going to have low motivation.
Um,
you know,
you're not going to feel as well,
you're not gonna want to do things.
So,
you know,
um,
if you're giving someone a medicine that,
that,
that nails there,
their testosterone levels down,
that's gonna really wreck wreck,
wreck havoc on their mental health.
And I just want to make a note to cause Ben Greenfield who again,
I really,
really respect.
I like that guy a lot.
Um,
you know,
it was talking a little bit with you about testosterone and um,
and uh,
and,
and cannabis and how it can drop it.
So I think there was three studies I saw done on,
on humans,
um,
and two of them a note at no statistical difference and drop into Saas and
levels and one study.
The other study noted a small statistical difference.
Um,
so,
you know,
I think that,
it may drop your testosterone levels a little bit,
but it's not gonna,
you know,
substantially drop them.
So just so people,
people know know that because I know that comes up,
um,
all the time,
you know.
Yes.
There's the,
as the,
as the dumb anti drug advocates like to say doobies caused boobies.
That is not right.
There's no goal associated with that.
No,
I'm joking.
Um,
risperdol causes,
that's a different issue.
Respire Dawson anti psychotic,
but spirits.
So,
so look,
I think,
I think the issue of whether cannabis is a gateway drug,
it's 100% clear that cannabis is a gateway drug.
The argument is we say has a hundred percent a hundred percent clear.
The argument is why.
Okay,
so the,
so it's quite clear that cannabis use oftentimes proceeds other drug use,
whether it's opioids,
cocaine,
other drugs.
Now one argument,
and this is actually a pro legalization argument,
is one reason it's a gateway is that if it's illegal,
you got to buy it from your friendly neighborhood dealer.
He might have access to heroin or cocaine,
other drugs.
And so eventually maybe you decide to try one of those other drugs.
So actually that's really why the Dutch legalized,
they wanted to create an avenue for people to use cannabis that wasn't connected
to other drugs.
Okay.
Another possibility is that using an addictive intoxicating substance,
you might like it and you might want to try other addictive,
intoxicating substances and it might prime your brain.
And then the third possibility really is that they're just some people who are
risk takers out there,
right?
They use,
they're going to use cannabis,
they're going to gamble,
they're going to in cannabis is a little bit easier to access than other drugs.
So they're probably going to try cannabis first.
So it's not really that that cannabis drives the use,
it's just the cannabis is first.
They're just curious people.
What's your thoughts on,
well,
what I will say,
I mean I'm just going to go back to the NAM report,
right?
And I mean,
I mean you quoted these people in your book,
um,
you know,
so this committee couldn't find sufficient data demonstrating an association
between cannabis use and initially the opioid use,
they found no compelling evidence to support the gateway drug theory.
So,
so again,
but that's the goal was the people that you quoted in your book.
So there's been more research done since then,
but what is have radically changed?
I would say things have changed some,
here's,
here's what I would rather say.
I think that probably it's a combination of these things,
right?
There's certainly an environmental factor where again,
if you're buying from somebody who's got an access to other illegal drugs,
maybe you try those drugs at the same time getting high,
it feels good and maybe you want to try other drugs and at the same time you're
just a risk taker.
Okay.
What is,
what nobody seriously ever said until about the last five years is that cannabis
could be an off ramp for opioids.
Okay?
And there's a lot of reasons to believe that's a really bad idea.
First of all,
cannabis,
if you actually need opioids for pain relief,
canvas is not a good enough pain reliever.
It's like alcohol.
It's a mild pain reliever.
It's not strong enough.
You're dying from cancer.
Cannabis probably is not the pain reliever that you need.
You need opioids,
okay.
And again,
the state level data is not as good.
If you want to really figure out what's happening to an individual,
the best way to do that is to follow that individual.
And there's a really good paper that came out in 2017 after the NAM reports that
they didn't have it.
That shows that people who used cannabis in 2001 this is based on a large
national study in the U S we're three times as likely to be using opioids three
years later.
Okay.
And that just intuitively makes sense to me.
And the other thing that people on the legalization side don't ever talk about
is who are the two countries that have the most cannabis use in the west,
the US and Canada?
Where are the two?
Who are the two countries that have,
by far the worst opiod epidemic?
The U S and Canada.
Okay.
But there's a real issue with that because the United States is also the only
country other than New Zealand that allows pharmaceutical companies advertise.
I mean there's a,
there's the amount,
it doesn't,
the amount of opiates that are prescribed the United States is fucking
preposterous.
I agree.
Particularly if he,
I don't know if you ever saw the documentary,
the Oxycontin Express,
but the way Florida used to be structured where they didn't have a database,
you could just literally go from pharmacy to pharmacy.
Yet we have a problem with the way we prescribed drugs in this country.
Opioids add drugs,
Benzos,
ssrs,
all were connected to Canada.
So it makes sense that it would filter over there.
Yes.
But what I would say is the people who think that cannabis is not part of that
overprescribing problem are deluding themselves.
And what do you think to that?
So he,
can you repeat the question again?
So,
so,
so I,
I agree with Joe the way that the access to opioids in the US.
I mean certainly it's come down a little bit in the last couple of years,
but you know,
Purdue Pharma,
there's a special place in hell for those guys,
but not,
it's not just opioids.
We prescribed too many benzos.
We prescribed too many add drugs.
We probably prescribed too many ssrs.
We prescribed too much in this country.
I think we all agree on,
I agree with that.
I think
that cannabis is another example of us looking for a drug to solve our problem.
But what,
what I'm okay,
again,
just from a clinical perspective,
um,
you know,
I can't just rely on,
on Diet and exercise for all my patients.
I have to use other tools.
And again,
like everyone here in this room,
like we're all pretty healthy.
I don't have a bad back or you know,
I don't have a mental health diagnosis or anything going on.
So,
you know,
I'll have to look at patients that are coming to me.
Right?
So the way I see it is that,
you know,
we just mentioned a bunch of other drugs,
antidepressants,
amphetamines,
all these sorts of things,
you know,
cannabis and again,
I'm going to separate the chiefs and the CBD.
It's an incredible medicine and it doesn't kill people,
right?
So as a clinician,
you know that,
that's so comforting for me to know that every single night I go to bed,
I killed zero people.
I know that.
Right?
So that's really,
really comforting for me to know.
Also,
I feel,
you know,
we just talking about amphetamines,
so we were just talking about,
you know,
ssrs.
I feel that cannabis,
you know,
particularly the CBD component can actually be more effective.
You know,
that's what I've seen a lot in my practice and other people have seen that as
well.
So,
you know,
I think that we need to need to take that into consideration when we're using
all these drugs.
And,
and Alex,
you know,
some of the things that you're saying,
they're quite,
you know,
um,
Aderville and,
and in a lot of things like researchers say,
you know,
are quite admirable as well.
And,
and you know,
they,
they feel that they can,
you know,
tell clinicians,
um,
you know,
give them really good advice,
but they're not the ones in the trenches.
They're not the ones in front of the people.
They're not the ones that have to have to chat with patients.
You know,
I have obligation to do something for my patients to make them better.
I really feel,
you know,
we just listed a bunch of drugs that cannabis is a really,
really effective tool and it doesn't kill anybody.
So,
you know,
because of that,
aren't gonna,
I'm gonna keep,
keep using it.
But like I said,
I'm always looking for other drugs.
I'm always looking for other,
you know,
alternatives to also help my patients.
But I think that,
you know,
using cannabis is a really effective tool for a lot of clinicians and it's
helped a lot of patients.
But what do you think about his argument about it being a gateway drug?
Other than what these people said in the study,
that there's no evidence that supports it to gateway drug?
What are your personal feelings about that argument?
So I don't feel that,
uh,
that cannabis is a gateway drug.
I do feel that,
you know,
one of the,
uh,
things that you mentioned earlier is that,
you know,
some people kind of had this personality where they're like an experiment,
right?
And they just,
they just want,
I want to try something.
So,
you know,
the fact is,
is that alcohol and cannabis just get introduced first.
Most of the time,
most people don't do,
you know,
coke or,
or LSD.
And then he say,
hey man,
let us try some,
some cannabis.
Right?
So it's just that,
that's the very first one there.
So if we,
so you could say anything that,
that that was easier access.
If there were some new drug that you know,
did something similar to alcohol or similar to cannabis and that was introduced
in,
in our society,
you'd be calling that the gateway drug.
And I do feel,
and I,
I do believe that nearly been demonstrated as being the gateway drug to almost
all the loosening of inhibitions.
Whereas the opposite could be said about cannabis,
that it makes you paranoid.
You might actually be less likely to try cocaine afterwards.
And I know that the name,
uh,
you know,
they don't,
they don't feel that the cannabis is a gateway drug either.
I mean,
again,
they said they found no compelling evidence to support the gateway theory.
And again,
I mean these are the people that you are growing and your book out.
Right.
Let me just go a little bit further.
They said in a retrospective cohort study,
it may,
it from e t a l and the 2016 examine that transition from cannabis use to the
use of other elicit drugs.
They found that the probability of initiating other elicit drugs after cannabis
did not differ significantly from the probability of starting with other illicit
drugs.
So it's just that cannabis is there first.
It's definitely not a gateway drug in any stretch of the imagination.
I just,
I totally disagree.
And there again,
there's 50 years of data on this.
I know the studies that he's quoting,
but there are,
there are many others.
And I think the argument is as to why.
And again,
I think the argument that that to some extent having access to this drug via it
illegally tends to open you up to other illegal stuff,
which to me is an argument for legalization.
So,
but I,
I do want to throw one thing out there,
you know,
I dunno how many of your viewers have teenage kids or you know,
it's probably,
they're probably more likely be teenage kids and
to have teenage kids.
But you know,
the book has,
the one thing that really worries me in the,
if we're talking about gateway drugs,
is that jewel and vaping are really a gateway to THC.
Vaping.
So you can,
you know,
you can run to that because,
well,
first of all,
it gets people,
it gets kids,
teenagers used to inhaling this illicit substance and you can actually retrofit
a jewel pod with THC.
They don't sell them,
but you can,
you know,
you can easily go online and look up how to do it.
And I think it really worries me and I've heard from a lot of parents in the
last month that there is an epidemic of Nicotine,
vaping and TAC vaping going on right now and that I think,
and,
and we're talking about 15,
16,
17 year olds inhaling pure THC,
the most dangerous form of this drug.
And I think unfortunately,
it's not going to take long before the mental health consequences of that become
apparent.
And,
and I really do hope that the book gives parents some tools to talk to their
kids about that.
If,
if nothing else,
last words.
Uh,
I was actually wanting to go over a few things that maybe I thought you might be
interested in.
Okay.
So,
um,
you know,
you're a dude,
you're over 50,
so prostate cancer.
So,
uh,
you know,
it's been shown that CBD may actually be beneficial for prostate cancer.
And one thing within that too,
in the same study,
they actually found that people who use CBD and we're on Chemotherapeutics is
actually augment it.
Um,
the,
uh,
efficacy of what you said,
they're good for prostate cancer.
Do you mean to prevent it or treat it?
Prevent and treat?
Yeah,
yeah.
Um,
and then they say,
you know,
THC may actually be a little bit effective because it can,
and this comes back to to stuff's a little bit,
it can antagonize Dha,
DHT.
So DHT is another testosterone,
you know,
hormone as you know,
and that's,
you know,
more,
uh,
more linked to prostate cancer.
Um,
one thing too,
you know,
we didn't get really get to talk about was a c t a n n a concussion is the oil.
I know a lot of your viewers are in a MMA and all about that.
And I tweet allowed to study other day that you retweeted and I really
appreciate that.
Um,
you know,
and,
and just,
you know,
it was a three year study showed that the mortality rate overall was,
it was nine and a half percent for people who had suffered a Tbi.
Um,
people who test it.
I know we talked about correlation causation,
but you know,
the THC users only had a 2.4% were tolerated.
The non,
she was just had 11.5% were telling me.
I mean that's really,
really significant,
right?
Like I suppose it's just THC and not CBD because CBD has been shown to be very
beneficial for people with traumatic brain injuries.
Yup.
It's actually the,
the are both beneficial.
Yes.
So that was,
you know,
again a correlation you can causation,
but I mean that the statute so over overwhelming,
like if it was,
you know,
non cheesy was like 3.5% of what to bring it up,
but it's 11.5 11.5% compared to 2.4%.
Um,
and again,
CBD,
yes.
And even yo mechanisms of action have even been identified with that.
It decreases inflammation in your brain post concussion.
Um,
you know,
one,
uh,
last thing too,
again,
there's only one study on it,
so,
and it was done on rats.
But you know,
I'm,
I'm a kito guy too.
Um,
but the study on rats,
uh,
interestingly show that if you have,
um,
if you do have a high fat diet,
uh,
that you can actually decrease sensitivity at the CB one receptor and they think
that that's just because there's an increase in your endogenous cannabinoids to
Hg and inanimate when you,
um,
w w when you do have a high fat diet,
and then,
uh,
kind of go,
okay,
sure.
Um,
and then all of the timers,
you know,
uh,
again,
I know you're plus a plus 50,
so you know,
cheeks see Saint Jo has Alzheimer's.
I know that he wants to keep doing this podcast for,
for forever.
So THC has been shown to inhibit the formation of Beta amyloid plaques.
So that's the,
you know,
the hallmark of Alzheimer's disease.
Um,
and then CBD CBD has also been shown to be effective for,
um,
for Alzheimer's disease as well.
You know,
it was a rat study that was going to get into,
but it's fairly fairly,
it's fairly detailed.
So you know,
it might be best just to say that it cane,
you know,
um,
help with rescue memory in patients.
If you do use CBD meaning and that it may actually reverse and that's been shown
before to,
they've done that in mice.
I got to interrupt you for one second.
Okay.
And I think you would agree this data is,
some of it's,
some of it sort of epidemiological,
some of it's preclinical,
it's very,
very early.
None of it really proves my game.
But let me say I'm a clinician.
Okay.
If someone comes to me and they have a concussion,
it's very frustrating just to say to them,
hey,
physical,
cognitive rest,
go home.
Okay.
It's really frustrating to say that to someone and also to,
you know,
the uh,
the high fat diet thing.
You know,
Joe and I both fall,
you know,
very,
very similar die.
So that's something that I want to share with regards to,
you know,
the,
the Alzheimer's disease,
we have really,
really poor medications for that.
And we have an aging population.
So again,
like Alex,
like you want to look at everything,
which is what I'm doing.
Like I'm looking at everything and I'm trying to make a clinical decision.
Am I using some things like without,
you know,
randomized controlled trials?
Of course I am.
But again,
I'm a clinician so I'm using,
you know,
mechanisms of action.
I'm using what I've see and clinic and I'm using epidemiological studies and I'm
also taking into account what other medicines do I have you base upon all the
data at this seems to be an effective treatment.
And I am absolutely not saying that you as a clinician shouldn't do that.
Especially you're in Canada at t it cannabis is legal.
You should,
you should use your best judgment.
What I'm saying is that when we're talking about policy decisions around
cannabis and THC and to a much lesser,
since CBD,
the advocacy groups have seized on this very,
very preliminary data to to say a lot of things about cannabis and THC that have
not been proven.
And you know,
a guy I know named Peter Bock,
who very smart,
uh,
he's a pulmonologist,
is at Memorial Sloan Kettering in New York and he wrote a piece in the Wall
Street Journal a few,
a couple of weeks ago talking about cannabis is limits as medicine.
And he said something that I thought was so well put,
which is the reason why people want cannabis to work for Alzheimer's and cancer
and a bunch of things.
Where does,
where there's really no evidence that it works is that we don't have good
treatments.
We want cures.
We want help.
We,
if we're clinicians,
I mean,
I'm not a clinician.
You're a clinician.
Want to be able to give people who come into our offices something.
But that hope is not a substitute for science.
It doesn't mean that it works.
And even you want,
you want your patients to have hope,
okay.
But that advocates,
the people who are using this to push,
especially to push THC and to capitalize on the public confusion around THC and
CBD,
I think that is a real,
it's a real disservice to people.
Okay.
Um,
listen,
uh,
I think we covered everything.
It's complicated subject.
It really is.
And a,
I think it's really important to discuss how complicated it is.
I don't,
I don't think there's,
I've,
I've never heard such a detailed analysis of all this stuff in,
in a way where you can get two opposing people that are,
you know,
very civil about it,
but agree on certain aspects of it.
I think.
I think we really highlighted all those things.
Joe,
thank you so much for having a thank you.
Thank you guys.
Thank you so much.
Really appreciate it.
Give out your social media please.
Sure.
So I'm a at Doc Mychart on Twitter.
I'm at,
I talked to my car on Instagram and a back doctor,
my car on a,
on Facebook.
So that's d,
r m,
I,K ,
And Alex,
your book is,
tell your children that's available now.
It's available everywhere.
It's available now.
Uh,
and uh,
if I had a copy,
I'd give you a copy.
I'll give you the copy of that.
Okay.
All right.
Well,
thank you guys.
Thank you very much.